faire émerger la réalité des profits
gigantesques que réalise et fiable mais
comment peuvent-ils mentir comme des
arracheurs de dents à ce point
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce mardi 13 juillet un
pic de vaccination à près de 800000
injection vanté par jean castex ce soir
mais aussi et surtout de nombreuses
réactions amères au lendemain de
l'allocution présidentielle si certains
approuvent l'extension du passé ni terre
à beaucoup d'autres se disent désabusés
gabriela talent lors de sa conférence de
presse à détailler certaines des
annonces les plus controversées de
l'allocution présidentielle on les
décrit tra avec nos invités
outre-manche plus de place au doute la
levée des restrictions sanitaires ce
sera bien le 19 juillet au royaume uni
le premier ministre britannique l'a
rappelé hier dans les zones sonne mis
sur la responsabilité individuelle de
ses concitoyens alors que le nombre de
cas dus aux variants delta est en hausse
et que la campagne de vaccination patine
[Musique]
effondrement c'est le terme choisi par
le ministre de la santé en tunisie où le
système sanitaire est dans une situation
je suis catastrophique paris place
tunique sur sa liste rouge des pays à
risque selon l'organisation mondiale de
la santé le pays a le taux de mortalité
lié aux coville le plus élevé du
continent africain et du monde arabe
[Musique]
après les annonces le service
après-vente face aux réactions
controversées sur l'extension du passé
ni terre le porte parole du gouvernement
gabriela talent promet des règles de
souplesse notamment pour les 12 18 ans
plus de précisions sur cette conférence
de presse avec notre reporter guillemin
rossi devant l'elysée bonsoir guillemin
alors vous avez donc des précisions
aujourd'hui suite aux annonces du
président de la république hier soir eh
bien oui tout à fait stéphanie parce que
comme vous l'avez dit les membres du
gouvernement font la tournée des
plateaux depuis hier soir c'est la
pédagogie de l'exécutif en actions à
commencer par gabriel atta le porte
parole le gouvernement était ce matin
sur le plateau d'europe 1 avant de venir
présenter un compte rendu du conseil des
ministres à 13h un compte rendu qui a
commencé par un point sur la situation
sanitaire écouter la quatrième vague
pourrait avoir commencé
ce n'est plus un risque c'est une
réalité l'épidémie reprend dans notre
pays elle reprend vite et c'est pourquoi
nous prenons des décisions
supplémentaires dès à présent nous
agissons vite pour prendre l'épidémie de
cours nous agissons tôt pour que cette
vague ne nous submerge pas au niveau
national le taux d'incidence accélère sa
remontée en une semaine il a progressé
de plus de 60% et il s'approche du seuil
d alerte et ce sont bien ces chiffres
qui sont à l'origine des nouvelles
mesures annoncées hier soir par emmanuel
macron parmi ces mesures bien évidemment
ce fameux pass sanitaire mais également
donc la vaccination obligatoire pour les
soignants mais pas pour l'ensemble de la
population comme la
annoncée gabriella talent l'exécutif
mise davantage sur l'incitation écouter
concernant la population générale
maintenant l'heure n'est pas à
l'obligation vaccinale mais à
l'incitation maximale le vaccin c'est ce
qui nous permet de vivre le plus
normalement possible
nous ne pouvons pas nous en passer nous
refusons de fermer à nouveau commerces
et restaurants parce que certains ne se
serait pas fait vacciner
oui il y aura une prime au civisme oui
les mesures de restriction des troncs
désormais davantage sur les non vaccinés
que sur les vacciner nous l'assumons a
franchement car sortir du coc vide est
un effort collectif
alors cette menace du pass sanitaire
elle semble avoir eu déjà un effet
notable puisque selon le porte parole du
gouvernement
il y a eu déjà 1 5 million de rendez
vous pris sur la plateforme d'octo libre
depuis l'annnonce des mesures par
emmanuel macron les mains gabriela
talent et a parlé de souplesse tout de
même pour certains français
et oui tout à fait un l'important le
gouvernement dont qui a annoncé qu'une
certaine souplesse seraient respectés
serait observée notamment à l'égard des
plus jeunes à l'égard des mineurs de
plus de 12 ans tout simplement je cite
pour qu'ils ne vivent pas un été
infernal autre annonce le gouvernement
devrait renforcer sa campagne de
vaccination à l'égard des seniors qui ne
sont pas encore vaccinés autre précision
plusieurs pays vous l'avais déjà dit
stéphanie ont été ajoutés à la liste
rouge dont la tunisie cela signifie
notamment que les voyageurs en
provenance de ces pays devront respecter
un isolement d'une dizaine de jours et
enfin et le gabriel attal a confirmé que
le régime transitoire de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire qui devait prendre
fin le 30 septembre sera bien prolonger
jusqu'à la fin de l'année 2021
remerciements aussi donc en direct de
l'elysée vous l'avez dit cette
prolongation notamment du régime
transitoire d'état d'urgence mais aussi
la vaccination obligatoire des soignants
tout comme d'ailleurs le pass annie
terres à usage quotidien autant de
mesures que le chef de l'état avait
pourtant promis de ne pas utiliser david
kelly fin je crois pas à la vaccination
obligatoire pour ce vaccin parce que
d'abord il faut être toujours très
honnêtes et transparents on ne sait pas
tout sur ce vaccin comme on ne sait pas
tout sur le virus est prêt je crois
beaucoup plus on travail de conviction
par la transparence
cal l'obligation conviction transparence
des mots lourds de sens mais qui ne
reflètent pas la réalité d'aujourd'hui
début décembre à l'aube d'une campagne
vaccinale compliqué emmanuel macron
affiche sa confiance envers les français
sur twitter il va même plus loin je les
dis je le répète le vaccin ne sera pas
obligatoire ayant confiance en nos
chercheurs et médecins nous sommes le
pays des lumières et de pasteurs la
raison et la science doivent nous guider
sept mois plus tard le constat est amer
et la confiance envers les françaises
semblent s'être évanouie bien sûr ce
changement de cap radical de l'exécutif
sur la vaccination intervient en pleine
recrudescence du variant delta mais le
rétropédalage est pour le moins
saisissant s'adapter ne veut pas
forcément dire menacé et pourtant
olivier vers ans n'hésite pas à employer
les grands mots à partir du 15 septembre
si vous êtes soignants et que vous
n'êtes pas vacciné vous ne pourrez plus
travailler et vous ne serez plus payés
oui le variant delta change la donne
mais le pass sanitaire élargi interroge
il est même considérée comme liberticide
par l'opposition
une forme de désaveu pour le
gouvernement a dès le départ l'idée d'un
passeport entre guillemets pour accéder
à des lieux publics du quotidien est
balayée par emmanuel macron hui même
dans la presse régionale
même son de cloche au sein du
gouvernement qui multiplie les sorties
dans les médias notamment cédric au le
secrétaire d'état chargé du numérique
qui assure sur europe 1 quelques jours
plus tard que l'exécutif écarte son
utilisation quotidienne car cela ne
correspond ni à la culture française ni
à la temporalité de l'épidémie
lors de son audition à l'assemblée
nationale le 11 mai dernier la députée
macro nist yaël brumby vais défend corps
et âme son amendement empêchant le pass
and i ter de concerner les actes du
quotidien
je crois qu'il est vraiment important de
l'inscrire clairement dans la loi pour
que le chaque citoyen de notre pays
puissent l'opposé à toute personne
privée qui pourrait avoir cette idée
saugrenue de d'imposer de pénétrer dans
son établissement à la possession d'un
talent pas sanitaire et ce n'est pas
tout puisque le secrétaire d'état aux
affaires européennes clément bonne
confirme dès le lendemain sur le plateau
de france 2 qu'il n'y aura pas de passe
sanitaire au quotidien pour les cafés
nous ne voulons pas d'une société à deux
vitesses dit il
des promesses tombé depuis aux
oubliettes à partir du début du mois
d'août le pass sanitaire s'appliquera
dans les cafés les restaurants les
centres commerciaux ainsi que dans les
hôpitaux les maisons de retraite
établissements médicaux sociaux nous
aussi dans les avions trains et cars
pour les longs trajets là encore seuls
les vaccinés et les personnes testées
négatives pourront accéder à ces lieux
qu'ils soient d'ailleurs clients usagers
ou salariés l'art de se contredire
poussé au paroxysme des mesures qui
portent atteinte aux libertés
individuelles pour l'opposition c'est
désormais au conseil d'état de trancher
la semaine dernière l'institution a
confirmé l'utilisation du passani terre
malgré la demande de suspension de
l'association la quadrature du net
le juge des référés considère je cite
que se passe ne porte pas une atteinte
grave et illégale au droit au respect de
la vie privée ou au droit à la
protection des données personnelles
mais les dernières annonces des manuels
macro change la donne puisqu'elle
concerne désormais les activités du
quotidien
alors question emmanuel macron et qu'il
allait trop loin politiquement mettant
une pression maximum sur les non
vaccinés est contraire aux libertés
publiques élémentaires l'instauration du
passé ni terre dans le quotidien des
français vatel créer une fracture et
mais diable dans la société
et quelle arrière pensée politique à
quelques mois de l'élection
présidentielle c'est l'objet de notre
écrite tâche soit tu es avec nous pour
en parler vincent chauvet maire modem
d'autun en saône-et-loire julien odoul
porte parole du rassemblement national
et enfin julie garnier oratrice de la
france insoumise bonsoir à tous les
trois merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors évidemment beaucoup
de de débat dans la société française
aujourd'hui dans les cafés puisque on en
profite encore un petit peu beaucoup de
réactions politiques
aussi après la pression mise par
emmanuel macron sur les réfractaires à
la vaccination je vous propose tout
d'abord d'écouter marine le pen la
patronne du rassemblement national recul
grave des libertés individuelles des
constructions de l'état liquidation de
notre système de protection sociale
la feuille de route de macron est clair
c'est encore les français qui paieront
l'imprévoyance et l'incompétence de nos
dirigeants
pour nous c'est non alain julien odoul
n'y pas sanitaires ni vaccination
obligatoire des soignants pour vous
rassemblement national pour nous racines
nationales un principe devait présider
un principe essentiel c'était le
principe de liberté marine le pen depuis
le mois de décembre dernier avait
demandé que la liberté soit respectée
liberté pour tous les français qui le
souhaitaient de se faire vacciner
et force est de constater qu'au début de
la campagne de vaccination les français
que nos compatriotes qui souhaitaient
trouver une dose de vaccin ne le
pouvaient pas pour les problèmes
évidemment que nous avons rencontré
problèmes logistiques les carences
problème au niveau européen et puis
liberté pour tous les autres pour les
français qui avaient des doutes et en
démocratie
les doutes sont légitimes le président
de la république d'ailleurs l'avait bien
dit au mois de décembre
on n'avait pas assez de recul sur ce
vaccin donc à bong deux français
n'étaient pas hostiles à la vaccination
vous savez on est le pays pasteur bombe
de france est donc ne sont pas hostiles
viscéralement et spontanément à la
vaccination mais je souhaitais attendre
souhaitez avoir plus d'information plus
de pédagogie et force est de constater
que le gouvernement a échoué dans ce
domaine là et le gouvernement depuis
donc ces six derniers mois a échoué pour
convaincre les français a échoué faire
en sorte que cette campagne de
vaccination soit un succès et comme il a
échoué
donc dans ce pouvoir de conviction comme
le lien de confiance avec les français
n'a pas été établie
aujourd'hui il emploie la manière forte
aujourd'hui on a de la brutalité parce
que les annonces du président de la
république était d'une brutalité inouïe
hier instauré clairement deux catégories
de citoyens faire en sorte que les
français n'ont vacciné soient considérés
comme des sous citoyens avec moins de
droits avec moins de liberté est tout
simplement revenir sur des libertés
individuelles fondamentales liberté
d'aller et venir liberté d'entreprendre
liberté de voyager tout cela est
extrêmement grave et aujourd'hui on voit
bien que le gouvernement masquer ses
échecs masquer ses insuffisances masque
aussi tout ce qu'il n'a pas fait la
recherche sur le traitement
les contrôles aux frontières le
renforcement des capacités la tanière
les risques de tordères va on va
évidemment voir ces mesures pardonnez
moi de vous ma fait en détail puisque
vous êtes trois robots on va aller plus
loin dans ce débat vincent chauvet comme
le dit julien ou d'une il aurait fallu
davantage convaincre et peut-être un
petit peu moins fort c'est parce que
vous en conviendrez c'est ce qui se
passe un petit peu les non vaccinés
en gros pas d'autre choix que plus ou
moins de rester chez eux ou de
pique-niqué dans un parc vide alors
peut-être en tout cas au début la
campagne de vaccination s'est bien
déroulé il y avait même plus de demande
que de vaccins ces derniers mois on
avait réussi à équilibrer la demande et
la livraison de vaccins et puis on se
rend compte finalement depuis quelques
semaines que à la fois là le rythme de
la vaccination stagne et en même temps
qu'on reçoit davantage de vaccins et
troisième élément que ce variant delta
qui est beaucoup plus contagieux se
répand extrêmement vite et qui
aujourd'hui représentent la majorité des
contaminations
donc effectivement il faut accélérer la
vaccination moi j'étais tout à l'heure
dans le centre municipal de vaccination
à autun et il ya beaucoup de monde qui
est venu s'inscrire parce qu'ils veulent
voyager parce que ils veulent
effectivement ils sont convaincus ils
attendaient à une partie qui étaient
attentistes et puis qui se dit
maintenant c'est le moment donc pas
forcément des gens qui étaient contre un
des personnels soignants mais aussi des
gens qui voulaient prendre le train
voyager qu'ils disent bon bah maintenant
pour pour avoir cessé liberté je me
vaccine effectivement c'est le pass and
i ter la vaccination c'est contraire à
l'esprit et général des libertés
publiques mais n'oublions pas que nous
sommes dans un état d'urgence sanitaire
il ya moins d'un an un moins d'un an et
demi et le présent d'un public disait
nous sommes en guerre nous sommes
toujours dans une situation d'urgence
sanitaire tout de même
ils ne devaient pas nécessairement être
prolongé une nouvelle fois et c'est
pourtant le cas ce qu'on ne traite pas
les les français comme des enfants julie
garnier clairement alors c'est vrai
qu'on est français ont semble-t-il
appris leur leçon à 800000 vaccination
aujourd'hui 1 je crois que le
gouvernement est toujours en guerre mais
c'est surtout il hier il a fait une
déclaration de guerre sociale parce que
dans les trois grandes mesures on va
dire qu'il ya qui ont été annoncés hier
à savoir le past and i terme il ya aussi
la réforme retraites chômage est aussi
l'absence de mesures envers les
profiteurs de guerre
on voit bien acquis emmanuel macron
demande des comptes en premier sur le
vaccin pour revenir sur le pass annie
terre bien évidemment la première le
premier de ces réflexes comme à chaque
fois c'est de revenir sur les libertés
et à aucun moment il n'a vraiment fait
ce travail de pédagogie comme on l'a vu
en espagne par exemple où chaque
personne est appelé pour prendre un
rendez vous ou alors aucune réflexion
n'a été fait non plus sur les ruptures
du système de santé
non il revient encore et toujours à son
jouet préféré à savoir la répression les
amendes ou encore l'intimidation
alors même que l'om est il faut le
rappeler n'est pas du tout favorable à
une obligation de la vaccination lui s'y
prête et je crois que ce qui est dommage
c'est qu'on passe à côté du constat que
l'on devrait faire ce qu'il y à un aveu
de la défiance politique aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui c'est la méthode qu'il faut
critiquer il parlait de transparence
vous l'avais dit dans votre reportage
mais où est la transparence des lobbys
aujourd'hui elle est toujours absente
il faudrait aussi qu'on parle encore du
la levée des brevets puisque puisque
nous avons une crise mondiale nous
savons qu'il ne pourra y avoir qu'une
réponse mondiale
or la levée des brevets qui justement
est la meilleure réponse à ça eh bien il
l'est toujours
c'est toujours pas à l'ordre du jour or
on sait très bien que même si on vaccine
les soignants et même si on vaccine
l'ensemble de la population
nous ne sommes pas à l'abri de variants
venus d'autres pays qui n'ont pas eu la
même vaccination et ça aussi c'est un
sujet qu'il n'a pas abordé juste juste
quand même pour dire ce qu'il faut
retenir c'est que mettre en avant
l'intérêt général
quand on se pose la question de jouer
encore la levée de brevets ou sont
encore les grands
this man des hôpitaux où sont les
excuses pour les mensonges mettre en
avant l'intérêt général quand derrière
c'est de la manipulation et des
mensonges ça fait vraiment mal quand
même
on va écouter une députée européenne
europe ecologie les verts michèle rivasi
écouter ce qu'elle a twitté hier c'est
l'apartheid dans le pays des droits de
l'homme
alors depuis 1 michèle rivasi a retiré
sa publication pour présenter ses
excuses pour l'emploi de ce mot jugé
maladroit elle se dit pourtant indignés
par les propos d' emmanuel macron
clairement il ya une ligne rouge qui a
été franchi julien ou 12 aujourd'hui qui
provoque par la même occasion une vraie
fracture une vraie scission entre les
français oui je le pense
les annonces d'hier sont extrêmement
inquiétantes
elles sont extrêmement inquiétantes pour
autant moi je ne cautionne pas et je
dénonce tous les discours excessif que
l'on a pu entendre de ce terreau 15
excité de certains fous furieux qui font
des comparaisons qui sont totalement
scandaleuse
moi je m'en tiens à ce qui a été dit je
m'en tiens au recul des libertés
individuelles ce qui est grave ce qui
est gravissime
je m'en tiens aussi au reniement de la
parole présidentielle de la parole
publique qu'il a plus aucune valeur
tous les ministres d'ailleurs vous
l'avez très bien montré dans votre
reportage tous les ministres tous les
députés de la majorité le président de
la république lui-même avait bien dit
qu'il n'y aurait pas de vaccination
obligatoire il ya encore quelques
semaines que le pass à lithaire ne
serait pas imposé pour elle dans un café
un cinéma ou un restaurant donc la
parole publique aujourd'hui n'a plus
aucune valeur ce qui est extrêmement
grave et ce qui peut aussi expliquer les
chiffres de l'abstention aux dernières
élections départementales et régionales
parce qu'il déconnexion totale
les gens n'y croient plus les gens n'y
croient plus voit bien que nous avons
des pantins qui disent tout et n'importe
quoi qui se renie au bout de quelques
semaines et ça c'est extrêmement grave
ce qui est très grave aussi c'est sur la
mise en pratique
parce que là nous avons eu les annonces
ensuite on a eu je dirais le lait petit
catalogue de monsieur attal la de
monsieur v rang avec les adaptations en
fonction des des publics donc là on
vient de comprendre et de découvrir que
les mineurs de 12 à 17 ans à l'avoir
donc le pas salutaire à partir du 30
août
et puis les différentes catégories c'est
à dire que les restaurateurs les
cafetiers qui ont été déjà été durement
éprouvée qui ont fait des efforts inouïs
pharaonique depuis un an et demi vont
devoir devenir des vigiles des policiers
vont devoir contrôler vont devoir donc
pour un café avec les risques évidemment
que l'on connaît d'une société qui se
fracture de plus en plus une société de
plus en plus violente
on a vu malheureusement ce qui s'est
passé en seine-et-marne avec le pauvre
petit théo donc qui est assiste à
assassiner pour une facture de 93 euros
qu'est ce qui peut se passer dans cette
société là s'il ya des conflits aux
abords des restaurants des cafés ou des
lieux publics pour ce genre de choses
donc clairement et pour les personnels
soignants aussi personnel soignant qui
étaient les héros de la république il ya
encore un an qui ont du temps avec des
efforts considérables qui ont dû
fabriquer des surblouse il faut le
rappeler avec des sacs poubelles quand
même les soignants de la sixième
puissance du monde et ses soignants
aujourd'hui sont désignés comme les
boucs émissaires et pratiquement comme
les propagateurs du virus donc
clairement il faut laisser il fallait
laisser la liberté à ses patients
soignants qui sont responsables qu'ils
sont adultes et qu'ils savent très bien
ce qu'il faut faire pour protéger les
restaurateurs ont demandé le report
d'application du passani terre prévu
début août ça a été refusé
julien au doute je viens de parler
d'aidé soignant qui seront désormais
contraints faute d'être sanctionnés et
pas payé il ya la question des enfants
aussi qui peut choquer beaucoup de
parents et entraîné beaucoup de
crispation parce que on a compris qu'ils
auraient une campagne de vaccination
dans les collèges ça veut dire quoi qu
on doit craindre que certains enfants
soient exclus de certaines activités
périscolaires ou de certains cours de
sport par exemple à la rentrée c'est
quand même pas pareil de vacciner un
enfant de 12 ans et un adulte vous en
conviendrez
on nous annonçait déjà une campagne de
déscolarisation quand les écoles ont été
réouvertes je rappelle que la france est
le pays développé qui a les
le plus longtemps ouverte les écoles et
on nous disait que des parents ne
voudrais pas placer leurs enfants on n'a
pas eu de vague de déscolarisation et
les parents qui font garder leurs
enfants à l'école les ont pas scolarisés
se comptent vraiment en quelques
poignées je pense que ce sera la même
chose sur la vaccination ou de toute
façon il ya déjà on va te scolarisés que
sur ce que le rassemblement national de
la france mais quelle garantie vous tout
simplement en tant que maire qu'est ce
que vous allez dire à vos administrés
quand des parents vous diront mais
quelles garanties at on pour des enfants
qui n'ont même pas fini leur croissance
par rapport à un vaccin qui qui a mis
voilà assez rapidement ce qui a été fait
rapidement les enfants c'est pas pareil
que les adultes
et ça il ya beaucoup de parents qui le
pensent qu est ce que vous leur répondre
et vont tout simplement en tant que
maire moi je suis papa médecin je suis
pas à l'om est ce jeu
l'académie de médecine un certain nombre
d'autres pays aussi vacciner enfants à
partir de 12 ans donc j'ai envie de dire
que s'il y a les autorités sanitaires
c'est aussi pour qu'elles fassent leur
travail et je voudrais me porté en faux
par rapport à ce que dit la france
insoumise
il ya eu la france a donné énormément de
vaccins un certain nombre de pays en
voie de développement alors les brevets
ont peut-être pas été levées mais tous
les brevets sont pas français mais des
livraisons importantes j'étais encore
tout à l'heure avec les des autorités du
burkina faso avec qui nous faisons de la
coopération décentralisée qui ont été
livrées massivement en vaccins depuis la
france il ya eu un plan pour l'hôpital
qui peut être pas suffisant on peut
toujours le dire mais avec un une
annulation tête avec du matériel
flambant neuf allez dans les hôpitaux
aujourd'hui il ya encore une négociation
pour une deuxième vague
d'investissements mais énormément de
matériel a été a été racheté et une
partie de la dette a été erratique
donc c'est simple de raconter un peu
n'importe quoi mais en tout cas oui il
ya eu et ce que dit julie redouble n'est
pas faux il y a eu une parole politique
qui a changé effectivement et moi je
prends ça plus comme une forme
d'humilité que d'arrogance les les la
situation a évolué défavorablement
avec une variante on n'attendait pas
avec une ralentissement de la population
vaccinée
même si aujourd'hui plus de 55 % de la
population est vaccinée 0% 12 entre
environ 50 et 18 ans ça veut dire que
dans la population majeure
il y a énormément une très très grande
majorité des personnes qui sont
vaccinées et qui donc sont confiance à
ce vaccin
on va laisser répondre julie garnier
mais avant cela en quelques petites
précisions ce soir apparemment encore
des évolutions puisque olivier verront
vient d'annoncer que le pass anitea 12
17 ans s'appliquera à compter du 30 août
un finalement et pas début août et que
le schéma de vaccination sera considérée
en france comme complet une semaine
seulement après la seconde dose 1 plutôt
que deux actuellement on voit quelques
petites modifications
julie garnier ça montre quoi une
certaine ouverture d'esprit du
gouvernement qui écoute les français en
colère je crois que ça démontre surtout
que les décisions sont prises on va dire
à l'aveuglé malheureusement il faut
quand même rappeler la façon dont a été
fait cette annonce c'est à dire qu'elle
a été faite de manière solitaire encore
une fois il n'y a pas eu de conseil des
ministres il n'y a pas eu encore de
débats au parlement nous avons tous été
devant notre télévision à apprendre
voilà ce qui allait se passer et le
service après-vente des jours d'après
allez un petit peu étayé les yeux nous
ou revenir sur certaines dispositions
c'est comme ça à chaque fois c'est comme
ça depuis le début de la crise et
honnêtement ça en devient lassant ou à
minima mais en tout cas énervant pour
pour d'autres et je crois qu'aujourd'hui
ce dont on a besoin c'est justement
comme l'avait dit le gouvernement mais à
croire que les paroles ne coûtent pas
cher c'est de transparence et de
démocratie et participation or voilà
c'est tout l'inversé à chaque fois qu'il
se passe c'est toujours des décisions
qui sont unilatérales et qui sont
contraignantes toujours avec les mêmes
et jamais avec les autres et je redis
mais toujours annoncé aujourd'hui que
les profiteurs de crise ne sont toujours
astreints du moindre effort c'est tout
bonnement insupportable
alors que on a besoin d'un plan massif
dans les hôpitaux alors qu'on a besoin
d'un plan massif dans les services
publics alors qu'on a besoin d'un plan
massif dans l'éducation et dans les
écoles qu'est ce qu'on voit c'est que
aujourd'hui alors que huit français sont
dix sur dix sont pour une taxation des
profits
eh bien le gouvernement se refuse
toujours à mettre à contribution ceux
qui se sont enrichis pendant la crise
pas seulement d'en préserver leur
patrimoine et se sont même enrichi les
500 familles les plus riches ont vu leur
fortune progressé de 30% cette année 30%
ayant quatre ans ça a presque doublé
qu'est ce qu'on attend pour mettre à
contribution justement l'ensemble du
pays et arrêter de faire porter la crise
uniquement sur les épaules des
travailleurs et toujours les mêmes c'est
un peu ça aussi qui est qui est agaçant
à la longue merci en tout cas tous les 3
vincent chauvet julien en 12 julie
garnier d'avoir été avec lui nous avoir
apporté vos opinions respectives merci à
vous donc quelques instants en direction
le royaume uni qui confirme la levée des
restrictions le 19 juillet prochain
malgré une recrudescence des nouveaux
quatre co vide
et puis l'inquiétude grandit en espagne
la région de valence la mise en place un
couvre-feu alors que la catalogne rapide
de nouvelles restrictions pour freiner
la vague épidémique
[Musique]
la grande bretagne a donc eu cinq ans
pour se préparer
cinq ans de psychodrame 50 négociations
politiques
est-ce qu'elle était prête le 31
décembre pour redevenir une île réponse
par du moment où le royaume uni avait
décidé de quitter l'union européenne il
ne pouvait plus continuer de bénéficier
de ses droits équivalents à si vous êtes
dans l'europe pas dans l'europe
vis-à-vis des 27 états autres c'est
juste quelque chose d'inconcevable
l'angleterre vab a un père grohl à nos
amis britanniques ont fait un choix en
2016 qui est un choix qui je pense va
impacter l'économie profondément sur les
prochaines années et va impacter des
générations les choses sont en train de
se caler de se mettre en place
est ce que les choses sont totalement
fluide réponse est non
[Musique]
c'est le nouveau phénomène à la mode
dans le monde du numérique les mft jeune
femme jill bolte token en anglais jetons
non fongible en français on vend du vide
parce qu'on a beaucoup de sous à placer
passez moi l'expression mais c'est du
foutage de gueule pour moi c'est un
outil qui est révolutionnaire et qui
changent profondément la manière dont on
gère la valeur je veux bien comprendre
que ça puisse intéresser des gens qui au
passage vous faire beaucoup d'argent
avec mais sinon à quoi ça sert
concrètement ça peut être un
investissement effectivement ça ça peut
être une première utilité mais c'est
bien plus que ça tout caractère
programmable de ces outils démultiplie
leur champ d'application on vivait avant
les nft je pense qu'on vivra après les
neft et dans quelques années on n'en
parlera plus si vous demandez à nos
grands parents quelle est l'utilité d'un
smartphone il était aussi très sceptique
finalement à l'époque
[Musique]
au carrefour d'une pollution insultes et
d'une nécessité technologique absolue
les terres rares sont au coeur des défis
du 21e siècle c'est un enjeu stratégique
pour tous les prix puisque leur accès
est aujourd'hui principalement chinois
en l'état actuel des capacités minières
connu la part chinoise et réserve
mondiale est de l'ordre de 37 % dans la
cadre de la guerre commerciale avec les
états unis la chine utilise sa position
comme levier de négociations mais il est
clair qu'avec les pénuries et les
tensions que nous allons connaître sur
certaines terreur il faut envisager
d'autres solutions
[Musique]
et
20h38 les bienvenus en direct sur rt
france si vous nous rejoignez malte
ferme ses frontières aux personnes non
vaccinées une décision qui contrarie
l'union européenne l'ue veut contraindre
lille d'accepter était spécial comme le
préconise le passé ni terre adopté par
les 27
car pass sanitaire ou pas chaque état
concert sa souveraineté en matière de
santé et de manière générale les membres
de l'ue eux avancent en ordre dispersé
concernant ce dispositif les détails en
images le pass and it erp ou l'échec
d'une coordination entre pays européens
il y a un an la pandémie de kobe de 19
débuté pour la combattre les états ont
tout d'abord mis en place dès
confinement et des restrictions de
déplacement avec fermeture de frontières
non coordonnées sur le continent
européen
avec l'arrivée de la vaccination et le
besoin de se déplacer
l'idée d'un pass and i ter émergent
objectif retrouver la liberté de voyager
en europe grâce à un document de
validité sanitaires un outil qui sur le
papier ne présente que des avantages
impasse sanitaire qui va de pair avec un
protocole de réouverture des frontières
à trois niveaux pour déterminer les pays
à risque au 1er juillet 2021 le pass
annie terre devient européen alors que
le variant delta gagne du terrain au
sein de l'union européenne c'est la
cacophonie
si certains permettent l'entrée des
étrangers d'autres ferment leurs
frontières pour se protéger un vrai
casse tête pour les voyageurs
une déception pour lui nous avons un
cadre européen
le passé ni terre qui est harmonisé et
protecteur il faut l'appliquer
prenons l'exemple de paulo il a 20 ans
habite au portugal et veut se rendre en
allemagne
paulo aura l'obligation de se soumettre
à une quarantaine et de présenter un
test pcr négatif
situation similaire au portugal où le
variant delta représente près de 90% des
cas autre exemple avec alan à 19 ans il
vit à londres et à réserver ses vacances
au portugal
il devra présenter son pass and it erp
ou un test négatif porter son masque et
respecter le couvre-feu
en grèce deux mille nouveaux cas sont
recensés le 9 juillet contre seulement
huit cent quatre jours plus tôt les
déplacements sur les îles grecques sont
réservés aux possesseurs d'un certificat
de vaccination ou d'un test négatif
le gouvernement envisage aussi des tests
pour les vacanciers venant du reste de
l'europe
de son côté malte n'autorise l'entrée
sur son territoire qu'aux personnes
complètement vaccinés décision vivement
critiquée au sein de l'union européenne
seuils d'âge pcr date de mise en oeuvre
les sujets de discorde ne manquent pas
depuis le lancement du projet de
certificats covin numérique en mars 2021
la mission d'union du dispositif suppose
et coordonner la lutte des états face à
la pandémie et redresser l'économie est
d'autant plus mises à mal que les
prévisions sanitaires sont pessimistes
selon le centre européen de prévention
et de contrôle des maladies
d'ici à la fin août le variant delta
pourrait représenter 90% des nouveaux 4
kovy de 10,9 au sein de l'union
européenne et en espagne la situation
sanitaire continue de s'aggraver la
catalogne reste la région la plus
touchée est le gouvernement régional a
annoncé de nouvelles mesures il n'exclut
pas à la possibilité de rétablir un
couvre feu
clémentine laurent et sur place un pas
en avant un pas en arrière on pourrait
presque dire que les restrictions en
espagne sont comme une danse de salon on
avance puis on recule
et précisément ici en catalogne et bien
on recule le gouvernement a annoncé que
désormais toutes les activités devraient
cesser à 00h30 cela inclut les magasins
mais aussi les bars les restaurants ou
encore les salles de spectacle autre
mesure bien on ne pourra plus se réunira
plus de 10 personnes à l'intérieur comme
à l'extérieur sauf pour les groupes
scolaires et puis enfin pour les grands
événements comme les concerts en plein
air par exemple toujours à l'extérieur
le public devra être assis alors ces
mesures ne devrait pas entrer en vigueur
avant la fin de semaine
mais en attendant et bien il est
possible que le gouvernement catalan ne
s'arrête pas là il étudie la possibilité
d'appliquer de nouveau un couvre-feu
pour la région alors cette situation est
bien forcément elle est due à la coved
19 qui grimpe en flèche toujours en
catalogne
le nombre de jeunes contaminés explose
et même si le nom
deux décés n'augmente pas tant que ça à
bien les services sanitaires sont
saturés alors face à cette situation la
france ressert un petit peu la vis à la
frontière les touristes français
revenant d'espagne vont devoir y
présenter un test négatif datant de
moins de 24 heures
s'ils ne sont pas vaccinés ça leur
complique quand même la tâche mais pour
l'instant les restrictions de la france
ne devrait pas aller plus loin selon le
porte-parole du gouvernement français il
n'est pas question d'interdire aux
français de partir en vacances en
espagne un prêt pour en parler nous
sommes avec patrick vits série à
directeur de détente consulting
présidents d'associations françaises et
experts du tourisme bon soit patrick
avis herria merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france c'est un petit peu
la cacophonie il ya un ministre d'un
côté qui annonce qu'il ne faut pas
prendre ses vacances en espagne de
l'autre côté l'ambassadeur qui nous dit
le contraire
comment les français réagissait ce que
l'espagne reste tout même plébiscité on
rappelle que c'est une des premières
destinations en des français en été
notamment absolument plus de 10 millions
de français étaient partis en espagne en
2019 donc c'est un enjeu considérable et
ils y ont dépensé environ 10 milliards
d'euros de dépenses donc c'est c'est un
marché très important
le varia vin bien aujourd'hui en fait
que perturber les espoirs d'une forte
reprise du tourisme d'espagne t-il d'une
des premières économie touristique du
monde
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure il ya une
forte augmentation du variant et du taux
d'incidents chez des jeunes de 20 à 29
ans on est aujourd'hui à 814 c'est
quatre fois plus que la moyenne de la
population et pour mémoire ces 200 en
france donc on à 2002 autorités qui
aujourd'hui vu s'affronter et on assisté
à une passe d'armes entre d'un côté le
ministre des affaires européennes
clément bonne qui a clairement demandé
aux français de ne pas partir en
vacances en espagne ou deux
donnant tellement de précaution qu' en
tout cas ce n'était pas une incitation
et l'ambassadeur d'espagne en france qui
lui a dit au contraire et il défend
l'économie bien sûr l'économie
touristique espagnol la catalogne
notamment c'est une grande région de
destination des français et pour les
inciter à partir alors effectivement les
français sont un peu perdus par rapport
à cette situation
on sait de toute façon que beaucoup
moins de français partiront cette année
en espagne donc probablement quatre à
cinq fois moins que ce qui ce qu'on
avait au cours des années précédentes
et aujourd'hui il ya des conditions qui
se durcisse progressivement parce que
pour aller en espagne il faut un
certificat numérique européen
il faut un teint un certificat de
vaccination bien sûr il faut un test
antigénique ou un test pcr de moins de
72 heures et tout ça a tendance à
évoluer parce que ces mesures changent
il faut savoir que les ils espèrent les
îles françaises sont encore moins
désirable pour les espagnols puisque les
contaminations aujourd'hui on les
pardons les arrivants des îles
françaises ont fait sur soumis
aujourd'hui à des conditions qui sont
encore plus strictes justement servir
c'est vrai que c'est pas forcément très
fair play de la part du gouvernement
parce que pour autant est-ce qu'on peut
dire que la situation est vraiment
meilleur en france on imagine que ça
dépend des régions enfin voilà on a
l'air de montrer du doigt l'espagne est
ce qu'on est
est-ce qu'on est mieux en termes
épidémique en france alors oui on est
dans une situation qui est bien meilleur
en france et tous les gouvernements et
cei en fait de de demander à leurs
populations de ne pas partir à
l'étranger où les conditions sont
souvent perçues en tout cas comme plus
plus complexe chaque pays défend en fait
je regardais sénat par du tourisme en
espagne
c'est ça représente 12,4 pour cent du
pib'
ça représente 150 milliards d'euros de
recettes donc c'est des enjeux
économiques considérables et d'un côté
on a un gouvernement français qui veut
défendre évidemment les français les
professionnels du tourisme et d'autre
part un gouvernement espagnol qui défend
aussi son d'économie et les régions
espagnoles qui veulent accueillir le
plus possible de touristes il n'empêche
d'emmanuel macro hier soir le pape
sanitaire est ce que on ne craint pas
que ça décourage justement les autres
touristes ans venus d'europe de venir
passer leurs vacances en france
voilà parce que en fait l'enjeu c'est
aussi que les gens perdront peut sortir
en fait de leur pays
cet été on en a aujourd'hui la
conviction mais c'est important pour les
français de petit à petit faire revenir
les clientèles étrangères
que ce soit les clientèles européennes
les vous à voir que 80 % des touristes
étrangers qui viennent en france via une
à deux heures de voiture de nos
frontières
mais petit à petit faire revenir se sent
pas le cas cette année des clientèles
lointaines comme par exemple les dix ans
clientèle asiatique qui aujourd'hui se
déplace pas mais qu'il représente un
chiffre d'affaires considérable beaucoup
plus important que celui qui est générée
par les clientèles françaises clairement
une question globale pour terminer
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment vous
en tant que professionnels du tourisme
que le variant delta est en train de
gâcher en quelque sorte l'été de
nombreux français claire non ces deux
facteurs anxiogènes
il ya encore quelques semaines les
prévisions étaient très optimistes et on
s'attendait à une forte fort redémarrage
de l'économie touristique en tout cas
auprès des clientèles françaises là
c'est clair que c'est une mauvaise
pierre qui est jetée aux professionnels
du tourisme parce que ça crée de
l'incertitude et probablement on devrait
assister comme dans certains pays à des
annulations j'espère les moins
nombreuses possibles mais ça complique
aujourd'hui encore plus la situation
merci beaucoup patrick avis série en
direction de détendre consulting
président de l'association française des
aidants
faire du tourisme et la pandémie et les
mesures restrictives duo kobe 19 qui ont
exacerbé la famine dans le monde ces
deux constats de l' agence des nations
unies pour l'alimentation
selon un rapport publié le 5 juillet
dernier la corée du nord pourrait faire
face à une pénurie de nourriture dès le
mois d'août
d'autres pays sont également menacés
yamina benguigui da les prévisions
alimentaire de la corée du nord
quasiment dans le rouge puisque le pays
pourrait connaître une pénurie dès le
mois d'août selon les prévisions de
l'agencé des nations unies pour
l'alimentation la fao
il manquerait à pyongyang huit cent
soixante mille tonnes de denrées
alimentaires pour subvenir aux besoins
de sa population
une pénurie qui se traduit notamment
dans sa production de riz qui affiche
plus d'un million de tonnes de moins que
l'année dernière
si le bilan est aussi négatif c'est en
partie à cause de la pandémie due aux
coronavirus un constat qui s'étend au
reste du monde la f1 au relais 811
millions de personnes victimes de la
famine dans le monde
ce sont 118 millions de plus qu'en 2019
juste avant la crise sanitaire ou
lorsque nous examinons les véritables
raisons de la fin toujours les conflits
les extrêmes climatiques les
ralentissements économiques sont les
principales raisons de la hausse de la
sous-alimentation à laquelle nous sommes
confrontés
en outre nous constatons que tous ces
facteurs sont exacerbées par le commis
de 19
est ce que nous constatons également
aujourd'hui c'est que l'accès à une
alimentation saine est un énorme défi
cela signifie qu'aujourd'hui nous avons
environ 3 milliards de personnes qui
n'auront pas accès à des régimes
alimentaires sains qui sont les régimes
dont nous avons besoin pour être en
mesure d'améliorer l'alimentation et de
lutter contre toutes formes de
malnutrition dans le monde
un constat soutenu par un rapport
d'oxfam publié le 9 juillet dernier
lo ng affirme que le nombre de personnes
souffrent de famine a été multiplié par
6 depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
la pandémie et les mesures de
confinement aurait fait ralentir
l'activité économique
le yémen en proie à un conflit qui dure
depuis 2014 doit également faire face à
une inflation inédite pour cette
dernière décennie le prix des denrées
alimentaires il ya par exemple augmenté
de 40% selon la fao et oxfam
la pandémie ne serait pas la seule cause
de la famine dans le monde se joignent à
elle le réchauffement climatique ou
encore les guerres civiles à une
troisième bague ducobu 19 menace la
thaïlande avec plus de 6000
contamination par jour et une campagne
de vaccination au ralenti le pays n'a
pas d'autre choix que d'appliquer des
mesures restrictives pour lutter contre
l'épidémie
antoine auger une cérémonie brève et en
comité restreint en l'honneur des
défunts du colis de 19 depuis le mois
d'avril
la thaïlande connaît une hausse de 90%
des contaminations et de 95 % des décès
liés à l'épidémie
et alors que seulement 5% de la
population est totalement vacciner
la crémation gratuite dans les temples
bouddhistes risque de provoquer des
engorgements le nombre de décès ne cesse
d'augmenter
rien n'indique que cela va s'arrêter je
ne peux pas dire que le chiffre
aujourd'hui est considérée comme élevée
car les cas pourraient continuer
d'augmenter
nous ne savons pas ce qui va se passer
j'espère que tout le monde sera prudent
essayez d'éviter cette maladie car il
détruit vraiment tout sur son passage
une situation très préoccupante pour les
autorités sanitaires désormais
contrainte de renforcer les restrictions
dans neuf provinces et d'imposer un
couvre feu aux 10 millions d'habitants
que compte la capitale bangkok
les déplacements inutiles vont être
interdits les gens ne seront pas
autorisés à sortir entre 21h et 4 heures
du matin sauf en cas de nécessité
nous nous excusons des difficultés
rencontrées par les personnes vivant
dans des zones soumises à des
restrictions maximales
mais cela va permettre de lutter
efficacement contre le virus
la thaïlande vaincra une façon de gérer
la crise que les thaïlandais juge
désastreuse depuis plusieurs jours le
peuple donne de la voix sur les réseaux
sociaux et appels à protester contre le
pouvoir
et si la colère est moins vive devant
les caméras elle se fait tout de même
ressentir le gouvernement fait tout très
lentement s'ils voulaient vraiment
imposé un confinement il aurait dû le
faire beaucoup plus tôt et cette façon
de transmettre le message aux gens il ne
prononce pas le mot confinement mais
utilisent d'autres termes cela provoque
de la confusion parmi la population qui
ignore s'il s'agit d'un véritable
confinement ou non
j'aimerais savoir ce que le gouvernement
prévoit pour nous dans tous les secteurs
d'activités les gens ordinaires sont
touchées et cela nous concerne aussi
chauffeur de tuk-tuk depuis ce matin je
n'ai pas réussi à gagner trois dollars
imaginez à quel point ce sera difficile
pour nous lorsque le confinement sera
mis en place
le gouvernement a décidé d'imposer un
confinement mais il n'y a aucune mesure
compensatoire ne pas permettre aux gens
de se restaurer sur place c'est déjà
bien assez mauvais pour les affaires
ces restrictions marque un véritable
coup dur pour la thaïlande qui avaient
peu à peu ouvert ses frontières il ya
deux semaines aux touristes étrangers
vacciner contre le kobe de 19 à ce jour
le royaume totalise plus de 345 milles
cas de kobe 19 pour près de 3000 décès
dont l'essentiel provient de la vague
des variants alpha et delta la situation
inquiétante également en tunisie pays
placés aujourd'hui par la france sur sa
liste rouge le ministre de la santé
tunisiens parlent d'effondrement du
système sanitaire tunis appel à l'aide
sa diaspora de l'autre côté de la
méditerranée pour plus de précision on
retrouve notre correspondant à tunis ben
hassen chébili un bon soir bassem
situation toujours inquiétante en
tunisie qui vient donc de passer
en rouge alors que les aides
internationales se multiplient notamment
depuis la france bonjour stéphanie
effectivement c'est une quatrième vague
assez compliquée qui essaye de gérer le
gouvernement tunisien avec un nombre de
décès qui explose le ms parle même d'un
taux de décès le plus élevé de tout le
continent africain
on a plus de 100 morts par jour c'est
vraiment énorme et c'est un maximum
atteint depuis le début de cette crise
du coronavirus un système de santé au
bord de l'implosion de personnel de
santé en appelle au gouvernement qui
pourrait qu'il puisse prendre ses
responsabilités et surtout qu'ils
puissent fournir aux hôpitaux le
matériel nécessaire pour pouvoir
travailler et gérer tous ces patients de
recrudescence des cas de pour la virus
une recrudescence des cas de
contamination du nord au sud personne
n'est épargné son ensemble du pays
malgré elle certains dispositifs mis en
place par le gouvernement notamment en
termes de restriction le grand tunis est
complètement isolé pendant le week-end
le couvre-feu est maintenu et puis il ya
des interdictions de circuler certains
gouvernorats sont même toujours en
confinement total la tunisie qui est
déjà passée en or aux jeux pour beaucoup
de pays notamment son voisin la libye
qui vient de fermer ses frontières c'est
le tour de la france qui a déclaré la
tunisie sur sa liste rouge
l'interdiction de rentrer ou de sortir
du territoire s'en trouvait être
vaccinés ou alors justifier d'un motif
impérieux ces quelques éléments aux
capus déclaré le porte parole du
gouvernement gabriel attac propose de
l'écouter en raison de la dégradation
sanitaire en tunisie ce pays va
désormais être classé sur la liste rouge
cela signifie que pour les non vaccinés
on ne pourra s'y rendront en revenir
sans motif impérieux qu'un test négatif
de -2 48 heures sera exigé pour les
personnes qui viennent en france et
qu'un isolement sera obligatoire à
l'arrivée un isolement de dix jours
contrôler vous le savez pour tous les
pays de la liste rouge par les forces de
l'ordre avec une verbalisation de 1000
euros pour les personnes qui ne
respecteraient pas cet isolement conduit
s'était pas nier la tunisie et craignait
de voir arriver à cette situation à ce
cas de figure ce scénario la tunisie
passera en rouge notamment avec la
france vu qu'on est au début de l'été
qu'il ya une forte diaspora tunisienne
établie en france qu'il comptait lever
on va passer ses vacances ici de
nouvelles restrictions alors que le
gouvernement peine toujours à gérer
cette recrudescence de coronavirus et
bassem la campagne vaccinale qui devrait
enfin s'accélérer la tunisie qui a
commencé à recevoir de nombreux dons en
provenance de plusieurs pays le
président même annoncé que l'armée
allait participer à cette opération de
vaccination effectivement stéphanie
c'est lors d'une réunion de crise qui
avait été organisée à carthage en
présence du président de la république
du ministre de la santé du chef de
l'état majeur et puis du directeur de
l'institut pasteur qui oeuvrent à
trouver des solutions notamment à
développer des vaccins ici en tunisie
ils sont rendus compte que vraiment la
campagne de vaccination avait du mal à
décoller en tunisie notamment par le
scepticisme de certains tunisiens mais
surtout et surtout par le manque de
vaccins qu'il y a en tunisie malgré le
fait que le gouvernement essaie de
multiplier ses partenariats avec les
pays étrangers
mais l'heure est aux dons le
gouvernement tunisien appelle vraiment
la communauté internationale à envoyer
des dons et notamment à sa diaspora
établie à l'étranger d'envoyer notamment
la des respirateurs haut niveau ont des
mac sans on est très peu on est très
loin tu te retrouves % de la population
seulement a reçu une première dose 5%
avons reçu une seconde dose pour une
population totale de 12 millions
d'habitants le ministre de la santé a
même annoncé que des paroissiens
pourront bientôt vacciner dans les deux
mêmes pour l'armée l'armée qui peut
vacciner et l'armée a déjà commencé à
vacciner notamment dans le sud de pays
dans la commune de tataouine et je vous
propose d'écouter un des militaires qui
oeuvrent à cette campagne de vaccination
dans le cadre de l'effort national et
sur instruction du commandant suprême
des forces armées le président de la
république
le ministère tunisien de la défense et
l'administration générale de la santé
militaire
afin d'intensifier et de vacciner le
plus grand nombre possible de citoyens
les citoyens n'ont d'autre choix que de
se faire vacciner alors vous l'avez vu à
ceux des paniers même les militaires
même les pharmaciens vont pouvoir
contribuer à cette campagne de
vaccination pour l'ensemble du
territoire tunisien encore faut-il avoir
assez de doses pour la population ces 12
millions d'habitants des dons continuent
à arriver un don de 500 mille doses est
arrivée sur l'aéroport de tunis carthage
en provenance du qatar d'autres pays
notamment comme l'egypte ont livré et
déjà du matériel médical et pris la
france et manuel mabrouki a déclaré que
huit cent mille doses de vaccins ainsi
que du matériel médical sera libre et à
tunis la tunisie qui qui dévore vraiment
qu'ils essaient de gérer au mieux cette
crise mais un gouvernement qui semble
complètement dépassés par la situation
et d une association d associations
société civile des citoyens et surtout
le personnel soignant et qui demandent
vraiment au gouvernement de prendre ses
responsabilités pour enfin sortir de
cette quatrième vague meurtrière en
tunisie merci ben hassen chébili en
direct de tunis
on ira cas présent un incendie a
provoqué la mort de 60 personnes dans un
hôpital le pays est durement touché par
la crise sanitaire les unités qu'ovide
inquiète tant leurs équipements sont
vétustes le gouvernement est pointé du
doigt alors que l'an passé le budget de
la santé elle atteignait même pas les 2
% de dépenses de l'état où elle est
bénie
c'est une colère qui ne cesse de monter
des centaines d'irakiens réunis devant
un hôpital théâtre d'un énième incendie
dans le sud du pays
la catastrophe qui s'est produite ce
soir a dit car à l'hôpital hussein
l'hôpital de quarantaine est une
tragédie devant laquelle je suis sans
voix
il semble que l'irak doit subir des
angoisses et des calamités l'émotion est
palpable sur le visage de cet habitant
de nassiriyah un mélange de colère de
panique et d'incompréhension alors que
l'irak pensée pelé aujourd'hui plus d'un
million 400 mille personnes ont été
infectées par le coronavirus et plus de
17000 irakiens ont déjà trouvé la mort
selon une source du département
sanitaire de la province de dhi qar
c'est l'explosion de bouteilles
d'oxygène qui serait à l'origine de
l'incendié
en avril dernier déjà dans la capitale
bagdad l'un des hôpitaux pour passion
qu'ovide avait pris feu faisant plus de
80 morts
de jour comme de nuit les hôpitaux
publics irakiens sont délaissés de quoi
alimenter la méfiance et la peur de
contracter le virus
les contaminations sont en constante
augmentation l'hôpital et maintenant
remplies de personnes infectées par le
courant n'a virus il y a des cas très
critique
une méfiance aussi lié au manque de
fiabilité des équipements bien souvent
de seconde main dans un pays on les
hôpitaux sont concurrencés par les
cliniques privées qui ont plus de moyens
sur twitter le premier ministre irakien
indique avoir réuni d'urgence mardi soir
un conseil composé de plusieurs
ministres et de responsables de la
sécurité pour se pencher sur les causes
et les répercussions de ce dernier
incendie qualifiée de désastre humain
reste avec nous dans quelques instants
retour sur les annonces des manuels
macron avec notamment la vaccination
dans les collèges lycées prévue pour la
rentrée 2021 écrit focus sur la relance
économique et sociale avec notamment la
réforme des retraites et d'assurance
chômage
[Musique]
l'idée c'est que lorsque les cellules de
la rétine ne sont plus capables de
répondre à la lumière puisqu'elles ont
dégénéré de rendre ces cellules
sensibles à la lumière nous sommes
inspirés d'une découverte qui avaient
été faites par des gens qui
travaillaient sur les alpes kb identifié
chez les algues des protéines qui
répondent à la lumière et entraîne la
formation d'un courant électrique comme
le font les neurones et comme le font
normalement les cellules sensibles à la
lumière dans la rétine pas ce qu'il va
dire qu'ils voient imposer il distingue
la lumière il distingue quoi exactement
par le patient avec le pop art par
exemple de reconnaître les passages
protégés dans la rue de détecter des
objets différents objets de petite
taille de vente à plusieurs niveaux en
passe de les compter de les attraper
mais comme c'est un patient qui ne
voyait plus rien depuis une quinzaine
d'années c'est déjà une source d'espoir
c'est évidemment pas un point définitif
du parcours c'est un une étape franchie
[Musique]
bienvenue à novossibirsk up nous sommes
au bord de la volga le plus long fleuve
d'europe
nous sommes chez vox harry
allons faire connaissance
vous avez choisi le jour à ba là on est
alors je suis arrivé en 2005 pour
étudier dernière fois que la france
était en 2011 demande pas un petit peu
non ah oui et c'est tous les fromages
tous les soucis sont toutes les
décroissants la pâtisserie traits de
caractère des russes qui te plaît
l'amitié les gens les gens très stylé
fallu les français ne soient pas je ne
pensais jamais de ma vie faire la plonge
et autonomie vous pouvez me souhaiter
bon courage
[Musique]
à très bientôt sur arte france
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que notre peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez comme moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative au sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu livre l'uniforme c'est quand même
des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui le droit qui doit éviter les
dérives idéologiques merci de le
souligner comment peut-on reconstituer
une sixième république qui ne soit pas
une république parlementaire
ça se passe en direct puisque on est en
direct il y a quand même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous dirigez une des plus vieilles et
sans doute d'une importante compagnie
taxi en france l'activité a repris sdap
elmander paris ou pas les chauffeurs de
taxi affiliés à notre plateforme ont à
peu près le même nombre de courses par
jour il avait en 2019
mais par contre dans l'activité rue avec
l'augmentation du télétravail avec la
vie sociale qui reprend tout doucement
et surtout avec l'absence de touristes
étrangers
les chauffeurs sont un peu à la peine
d'aller à cuba 5 6 ans vous aviez un
monopole est sûre ce est arrivée la
concurrence les vtc gros gros choc
d'offre
on est passé de on a doublé 20000 à 45
mille véhicules
oui on peut pas à l'infini augmenter le
nombre de véhicules dans paris et
d'ailleurs la loi d'orientation sur les
mobilités réguler même le nombre de
trottinettes et tant mieux parce que
chaque usage pour chaque besoin de
chaque client doit être organisé
chaque jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs se jouer mais les
règles ne sont pas toujours respectées
les couleurs changent de camp les pions
prennent la place des rois de films
stratégies peuvent porter des résultats
inattendus
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire je suis allée de chômeurs et
chaque semaine dans l'échiquier mondial
nous analyserons les coups les plus
complexes du jeu politique
internationale
à bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'émission tout de
suite voici les titres de l'actualité de
ce mardi 13 juillet le pas de sanitaires
s'appliquera à compter du 30 août pour
les 12 à 17 ans déclaration ce soir
d'olivier verront la mesure annoncée par
emmanuel macron en référence et des
dents depuis hier soir
ce mardi gabriela tadla prenez la
souplesse pour éviter de faire passer à
des millions de saint denis en été je
cite infernal prochaines échéances la
rentrée scolaire une allocution une
entrée en campagne peut-être outre le
covin evegno mettront à dessiner la
calendrier des réformes à venir à moins
d'un an des présidentielles de
l'explosive réforme des retraites à la
controversée assurance-chômage le chef
de l'état appelle à construire la france
de 2030 en continuant le cap du quoi
qu'il en coûte
un appel à manifester interdit par la
préfecture a d'ailleurs été lancé pour
demain nous en parlerons avec un autre
éditorialiste et lexie poulain à cuba
une centaine de personnes ont été
arrêtées après les manifestations de
dimanche lille qui est durement frappée
par une crise économique et sanitaire
avait vu des milles
et de cubains manifesté aux cris de
liberté et à bas la dictature
giovanna demi soutient cet appel à la
liberté du peuple cubain
de retour sur sa terre natale plus de
200 ans après son décès la dépouille du
général gudin morts pendant la campagne
de russie y est intime de napoléon est
arrivé aujourd'hui sur le sol français
en juillet 2019 une équipe franco russe
avait exhumé serre est une opération et
un rapatriement qui font polémique
accueilli avec les honneurs des vétérans
à l'aéroport du bourget le général dont
le nom est gravé sur l'ad de triomphe ne
pourra pourtant pas reposer aux
invalides tout de suite
[Musique]
olivier ferrand précise le schéma de la
vaccination elle sera considérée complet
une semaine après la seconde dose et non
plus deux comme actuellement
le ministre de la santé a également
dévoilé la date du 30 août pour
l'extension du passani terre aux 12 17
ans on en parle avec guillemard aussi
notre reporter devant l'elysée guillemin
olivier verrons qui vient donc annonce
d'annoncé ce soir que le pack sanitaire
avait été repoussée au 30 août 1 pour
les 12 17 ans que c'était nécessaire
ah oui tout à fait stéphanie nécessaire
comme car comme vous savez très
certainement les jeunes sont très très
peu nombreux à être vaccinés les mineurs
sont 15% seulement à avoir reçu une
première dose 2% à peine avoir reçu une
deuxième injection sauf que pour
présenter un schéma vaccinal complet et
bien cela prend du temps il faut déjà
avoir son premier rendez vous il ya un
délai est respecté entre les deux
injections et puis la validation du pass
sanitaire n'est pas immédiate même si
comme vous l'avait déjà dit stéphanie
olivier ferrand vient d'annoncer que la
validation du schéma vaccinal complet se
ferait non pas au bout de deux semaines
mais au bout d'une semaine sauf sauf
pour les départs à l'étranger cela
signifie tout de même que pour une
personne par exemple qui ce feu qui ce
qui aurait reçu sa première dose
aujourd'hui avec le vaccin johnson and
johnson et bien son schéma vaccinal
complet serait
son schéma vaccinal serait considéré
comme complet pardon seulement le 3 août
le 10 août avec les vaccins de pfizer et
moderna est encore bien plus tard avec
les vaccins astrazeneca c'est vous dire
si ce pass sanitaires il menaçait une
partie des vacances de millions
d'adolescents et guy main les 12 17 ans
qui devront il ne faut pas s'emballer un
de toute façon se faire vacciner
ben oui bien entendu puisque ce pass
tanit et il va de toute façon ou rentrer
en vigueur donc le 30 août
un peu plus tard que pour le reste de la
population mais tout de même alors cela
dit cela devrait être facilitée pour les
retardataires puisque rappelez vous
emmanuel macron a annoncé dans ces
mesures le déploiement de campagnes de
vaccination dans les collèges et les
lycées il reste que les défis y est de
taille puisque l'on compte actuellement
6 millions d'élèves du second degré
c'est-à-dire des collégiens des lycéens
c'est à dire les les adolescents entre
12 et 17 ans cela fait 6 millions
d'adolescents qui pour le moment je vous
le rappelle ne sont quasiment pas
vacciner et qui devront bien l'être
d'ici le 30 août c'est à dire dans à
peine un mois et demi
merci gamin rossi pour en parler nous
sommes avec alix rivière vice présidente
fcpe de seine-saint-denis bonsoir
l'écrit wierre merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france petit report 12 17
ans avancé olivier verrons ce soir c'est
un soulagement du côté des parents
d'élèves dans la mesure où on a été en
retard scrutin ni surtout
disons que cela juste ya un calendrier
un peu plus logique ça peut paraître
normal mais mais non s'interroge
beaucoup sur cet apartheid social qui va
être mis en place et sanitaire puisque
on sait que les les familles qui ne
voient là qu'ils ne vont pas vers les
lieux de culture ou qui ne peuvent pas
financer des des loisirs qui part des
attractions ce genre de choses oulalala
n'existait va être beaucoup moins
beaucoup moins omniprésente et pour
l'instant on n'a pas de détails
concernant l'école pincer et nous on a
quand même passé notre année à chercher
les médecins scolaires des infirmières
donc on se demande bien comment est ce
que le système scolaire va s'adapter à
cette nouvelle réalité de peut-être
vacciner les élèves en milieu scolaire
sachant qu'en plus il va faire à
l'autorisation des parents et que vu le
peu de pédagogie et de débats citoyens
qu'il ya pu avoir sur ce sujet parce que
c'est pas ça s'est pas produit à
l'assemblée ça s'était produit au sénat
je ne sais pas de quoi on y parle si ce
n'est pas de parler de cela et nous en
tout cas les parents ce qu'on offre sur
le terrain où tout au long de l'année
c'est qu'on a fait assez peu qu'a
finalement du bien-être des élèves parce
que effectivement l'ex rivières ont fait
référence au fait que le président
mettront certainement annoncé une
campagne de vaccination dans les
collèges et les lycées c'est vrai que ça
peut peut-être être surprenant est ce
qu'on doit craindre
peut-être une opposition de la part des
parents selon vous parce qu'on imagine
que vacciner un enfant de 12 ans n'est
pas exactement pareil que de vacciner un
adulte évidemment que les parents vont
s'inquiéter et moi ce qu'ils montrent ce
qui me choque c'est qu'en france on a
quand même et ça choque tous les parents
en france on a quand même suffisamment
de forces intellectuelles pour vraiment
débattre sur ce sujet de façon
intéressante constructive et peut-être
convaincre ou pas les 25%
d'ailleurs ce chiffre intéressant
puisque c'était en seine saint denis
c'est le même pourcentage de parents qui
ne voulaient pas envoyer leurs enfants à
l'école
à la fin du premier confinement dur mais
en l'occurrence là c'est quelque chose
d'arbitraire enfin on a du mal à
comprendre comment est ce que le
président se situe là dessus sur sur un
débat éclairé d'experts vraiment le
conseil scientifique c'est une nature
spécifique à cette pandémie
on a plein de choses en france qui
peuvent nous aider l'académie de
médecine la sucette pédiatrie des gens
comme agnès goffart comme patrick berche
un des gens qui sont hyper calé sur ces
sujets là et qui pourrait être force de
proposition et ou de sa non et nous nos
plus grosses angoisses c'est que cette
quatrième vague va de nouveau plonger
les enfants les élèves dans une dans un
chaos scolaire et ce sera la troisième
année consécutive et nous ne sommes pas
prêts à affronter cette quatrième vague
d'un point de vue massification d'un
suivi scolaire à 10 ans pour tous les
élèves de france justement les
fédérations de parents d'élèves est ce
que vous allez demandez peut-être
davantage de concertation de deux débats
avant la réalisation de ces campagnes de
vaccination parce que les parents
peuvent avoir des craintes légitimes que
tout simplement voilà du jour au
lendemain ces campagnes soit organisée
et que du jour au lendemain peut-être
les élèves non vaccinées soit exclu de
certaines activités peut-être péri
scolaires ou des cours de sport sait-on
jamais mais effectivement falloir que le
ministre ait et le président précise ce
genre de choses parce que oui les
parents sont là pour l'instant
y'aura vacances ou pas faut se rappeler
quand même que c'est un enfant sur trois
qui part en vacances en france donc
c'est pas non plus une majorité est là
la surprise de la rentrée des risques
d'être avoir force de douche froide oui
bien sûr
tout si on peut pas accueillir les
enfants à l'école oui bon je souhaitais
que ce cette décision soit prise à
l'issue peut-être d'un débat citoyen
c'était peut-être la meilleure solution
pour apaiser les craintes dans la mesure
où en plus on le président macron à
chercher
à voir comment dire une coopération
européenne sur tout ce qui est gestion
de la vaccination
moi je m'étonne que qu'on ne soit pas
capable de faire appel faire appel à la
fois aux corps intermédiaires à la fois
les élus de la république à l'assemblée
et au sénat ce fins et c'est quand même
préoccupant de se dire que le débat des
présidentielles prend pas sur tout y
compris sur sur un sujet aussi important
la rentrée comment vous l'abordez
justement avec ce spectre du variant
delta on peut se dire ça y est
maintenant on est habitués on va pouvoir
réagir on s'est toujours autant la
confusion au sein des établissements et
les choses pèse sur les directeurs
d'établissements notamment la pandémie
n'a jamais quitté l'école depuis depuis
mars 2020 il faut se rappeler quand même
ce la fin où il ya eu le confinement
tout ça mais dès la reprise la pandémie
n'a jamais quitté l'école et c'est ce
qui ad'ailleurs forcer toutes les
équipes scolaires y les élèves aussi à
dire à des situations au tout au long de
l'année kilifa qui n'était absolument
pas sereine au regard des apprentissages
nous on a demandé des choses très
précises qui pourrait jeter le lycée
français de l'étranger ils ont tous fait
des groupes restreints dans leur classe
pourquoi est-ce que ce point pourquoi
est ce qu'on arrive à faire sur les
lycées français à l'étranger
on n'arrive pas à le transposer en
france métropolitaine dire pourquoi
est-ce que des classes de 15,17 ça
fonctionne mieux que des classes aa 28
ya tout un tas de raisons mais en
paraître pandémique c'est super et c'est
super important
et cette distanciation des élèves et des
adultes qui en ont la charge
je vous rappelle quand même que ça fait
un an et demi qu'on nous le demandons
donc c'est enfin rien une année oui
merci alex rivière rappelle que vous
êtes de 2,5
merci d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur arte france j oui allez on arrive
avec d'être inquiet on dit très inquiet
sur les écoles privées sous contrat qui
ne qui ne maîtrisent pas
les classeurs potentiel dans la mesure
où ils ont une offre cynique commercial
le dire nous on accueille les enfants en
plein jour et ça c'est extrêmement
dangereux et là on est très inquiet
lassus au niveau de la gestion pour
avoir les pouvoirs publics merci de
votre écoute
merci à vous surtout alix à rivière
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france et outre le qu'ovide emmanuel
macron est aussi revenu sur les réformes
attendues comme celles par exemple des
retraites suspendu en mars 2020 à cause
de la crise sanitaire ce volet majeur du
quinquennat sera traité à la rentrée en
concertation nous dit-on avec les
partenaires sociaux
françois qui ce qui évite ch avec
cyrielle benavides bull bullion on la
croyait enterrée elle est finalement
bien de retour la fameuse concertation
sur la réforme des retraites
j'ai toujours tenu un langage de vérité
oui notre système est injuste
avec quarante deux régimes différents il
entretient des inégalités majeur il
faudra aller vers plus de simplicité
pour plus de justice
j'ai entendu les débats sur le moment
faut-il faire cette réforme dès ce mois
de juillet à la rentrée ou bien plus
tard alors si je demande aux
gouvernements de jean castex de
travailler avec les partenaires sociaux
sur ce sujet dès la rentrée je ne
lancerai pas cette réforme tant que
l'épidémie ne sera pas sous contrôle et
la reprise bien n'assurons pas de
calendrier précis donc puisque
l'épidémie devrait selon toute
vraisemblance perdurer jusqu'à au moins
2000 22
la réforme pourrait même être renvoyée
au prochain mandat présidentiel
une chose est sûre emmanuel macron
évoque clairement le recul de l'âge de
départ à la retraite
pourtant ce n'est pas ce qu'il prévoyait
dans son programme en 2017
c'est même exactement le contraire de ce
qu'il avait promis
deux ans après son élection en avril
le président de la république était
encore à peu près sur la même ligne mais
est ce qu'il faut reculer l'âge légal
qui est aujourd'hui à 62 ans
je ne crois pas je ne crois pas pour
deux raisons la première est un peu
direct c'est que je me suis engagé à ne
pas le faire je pense est quand même
mieux sur un sujet aussi important de
faire son ce qu'on a dit par contre
travailler plus ça peut se faire d'une
autre manière c'est d'allonger la durée
de cotisation est de laisser le libre
choix
ce qui est d'ailleurs au coeur du projet
qui est porté par jean paul delevoye en
juillet de la même année jean paul
delevoye au commissaire à la réforme des
retraites rende est justement son
rapport la question de l'âge pivot il
était posé l'inquiétude grandissait du
côté des syndicats et les manifestations
s'étaient enchaînés
[Musique]
début mars 2020 le gouvernement a
finalement utilisé l'article 49-3 pour
faire passer sans vote son texte sur la
réforme en première lecture à
l'assemblée de faire vivre mais la
pandémie de coronavirus est passé par
larbi mettant à l'arrêt l'agenda du
gouvernement
en déplacement dans le département du
lot les 2 et 3 juin dernier emmanuel
macron a rallumé la mèche en évoquant
les décisions difficiles à venir qui l'a
confirmé lors de son allocution ce lundi
soir le président de la république
n'écoute que lui il parle de
concertation sur les retraites mais il
annonce déjà qu'il faudra travailler
plus qu'est-ce que vous voulez qu'on
aille discuter avec le gouvernement
mais l'agenda social du président ne
s'arrête pas là et les syndicats vont
devoir discuter d'un autre sujet avec le
gouvernement car si les dates de la
réforme des retraites reste flou la
réforme de l'assurance chômage sera elle
je cite pleinement mises en oeuvre dès
le 1er octobre et pour en parler on
retrouve alexis pour lancer notre
rubrique lennikov ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir alexis poulain merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france à hyères
vous le savez donc le président a fait
plusieurs annonces à on était ensemble
pour les commenter mais il y avait aussi
celles concernant la relance économique
et social à commencer par cette réforme
des retraites et l'assurance chômage on
commence par la réforme des retraites
c'est ce qui pique le plus d'ailleurs
fin des régimes spéciaux âge légal
repoussé mais ne macron la remise sur la
table avec un bémol elle sera engagée
dès que les conditions sanitaires nous
permettront en gros qu'est ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire qui mêle macro
obéit à un agenda qui n'est pas celui ni
des échéances électorales qu'elles
soient municipales régionales ou autres
ni même ce qu'attend le peuple français
les partenaires sociaux il est là parce
que il a été élu sur une promesse de
réformes il était celui qui devait
réformer cette france sclérosé la faire
entrer dans la modernité et faire en
sorte que la france devienne un pays
comme un autre
que ce soit sur la réforme des retraites
la réforme de l'assurance chômage ou
autre l'idée est simple c'est que la
france ne doit plus être cette
république sociale qu'elle a été elle
coûte trop cher et puis finalement il
faut créer de nouveaux marchés de la
dette donc mails macro aujourd'hui dans
son rôle de président de la république
cette mise en scène qui l'a fait hier
devant la tour eiffel avec ses millions
de caméras
c'était assez particulier pour
l'allocution présidentielle eh bien il
est là pour dire peu importe il ya le
grand navire us il y à une crise mais je
dois m'en tenir à mon agenda à mon ordre
du jour est celui là est claire je dois
faire des réformes sans cela je ne
pourrais pas me représenter parce que je
n'aurais eu aucune réforme
et donc il va pousser évidemment pour
que la réforme de l'assurance chômage la
récente des retraites arrive à terme
alors même que les partenaires sociaux y
compris le medef et d'autres sont tout à
fait vent debout contre cette idée de
réforme qui n'arrive pas au bon moment
puisque entre temps est arrivée une
crise sanitaire qui complique tous les
plans évidemment des malades alors il
n'y a pas que la réforme des retraites
un il ya aussi la controversée réforme
de l'assurance chômage qui fait grincer
des dents qui a été abordé par le chef
de l'état justifie d'ailleurs emmanuel
macron le modèle social français est un
jeu
lyon qu'il nous faut protéger pas sûr
que les partenaires sociaux l'entendre
de la même oreille
mais pas du tout d'ailleurs c'est un
discours à tiroirs dire qu'il faut
protéger le modèle social français en le
détruisant c'est tout à fait pervers est
tout à fait d'ailleurs manipulateur je
ne vois pas comment d'éléphants social
français en faisant une tête coville qui
va coûter des milliards d'euros à la
france alors même que nous ne savons pas
comment nous allons rembourser
aujourd'hui nous avons avec la banque
centrale européenne
un euro qui nous permet évidemment
d'emprunter sur des marchés
internationaux et c'est formidable et
emelin qu'on a profité de ce plan de
relance en disant que les gaffes en
payeront les grandes entreprises
internationales pedro et puis on se rend
compte que washington n'est pas tout à
fait d'accord et qu'il va falloir faire
autre chose et que finalement cette taxe
qui devait financer cette dette covin ne
va peut-être pas arrivé au bon moment
opportun alors cette dette qu'ovide
c'est très simple c'est endettement de
l'état un point tel que nous allons bien
étouffés par la dette c'est nous les
français les contribuables qui allons
devoir la payer d'une façon ou d'une
autre
quoi qu'il en coûte il est le couac il
va vous en coûter nous en coûter que ce
soit l'assurance chômage ou les
retraites travailler plus plus longtemps
être moins indemnisé si jamais vous êtes
dans la difficulté de chercher un emploi
c'est ça le programme des mâles macron
c'est d'une violence sociale sans nom
c'est la solde pour tous compte de la
république sociale et c'est son
programme et il le dit d'ailleurs
ouvertement lors de son allocution
d'hier
finalement en utilisant la crainte du
virus pour faire passer ce programme qui
est d'une violence inouïe par rapport à
ce que nous connaissons de l'état social
français pour dire que tout ça doit
changer et que dorénavant c'est tous
contre tous et chacun pour soi c'est le
programme des mâles macron c'est ainsi
qu'il l'a présenté en disant que
finalement c'est les non vaccinés qui
sont responsables de la non violence de
la perte de compétitivité de l'économie
française donc il trouvera des boucs
émissaires mais au final tous les
français vaccinés ou non devront
travailler plus longtemps auront moins
de retraite et vont voir la disparition
de la république sociale sous le régime
de belle macro alors il a précisé ses
ambitions emmanuel macron 1 pour les
prochains mois on imagine avec en
perspective une campagne de réélection
il
réindustrialiser la france - dépendance
de l'étranger
c'est un tournant c'est encore une fois
une manipulation assez grossière de la
part de ce président bak roues puisqu'il
pense que la france va devenir
indépendante en étant totalement
dépendante de vaccins allemands et
américains très bien après tout pourquoi
pas à la souveraineté finalement il ne
sait pas ce que ça veut dire mais là ça
devient vraiment critique parce que
qu'est-ce qu'il a déroulé il ya dans son
discours il a parlé de ses secteurs qui
vont être les secteurs d'avenir
l'intelligence artificielle bien sûr les
nouvelles technologies tout ce qui est
dans ce fameux livre le grétry 7 du
forum de davos de klaus schwab de dire
que davantage le numérique va sauver
l'économie et c'est là que les nouveaux
emplois pour se créer mais il y as entre
la création des nouveaux emplois et la
destruction des emplois existants une
période très difficile où finalement les
gens qui vont perdre leur emploi ne vont
pas en retrouver ne pourront pas être
formé pour être les futurs travailleurs
de demain alors on voit bien que jean
michel blanc pierre s'active pour faire
en sorte que le bac ne veulent plus rien
dire que l'éducation nationale ne soit
plus là pour créer des citoyens éclairés
mais des travailleurs formaté pour
finalement que servir d'armé de réserve
à ce qu'il va être l'économie numérique
de demain
mais le discours des malades mâcon
d'hier qui moi m'a inquiété à inquiéter
de nombreux français est en train
simplement de mettre en place ce qui est
écrire dans ce grétry c'est de dire que
le numérique l'écologie verte doit
prendre le dessus et que les poches de
croissance seront dans ces nouveaux
emplois dans ces nouveaux secteurs
d'activité or aujourd'hui il faut les
filières il faut la capacité de le faire
et qui sont les champions du numérique
qui sont les champions également de
l'écologie ou du moins de l'énergie
verte et renouvelable
ce ne sont pas les français ce ne sont
même pas les européens se sont encore
une fois les gars femmes les grandes
entreprises américaines ou chinoises qui
vont encore gagner davantage d'argent
avec les politiques mises en place par
nos gouvernants notamment emmanuel
macron et ça me fait vraiment beaucoup
de geeks et pitié même d' inquiétude de
voir qu'un président français est
capable de parler de souveraineté sans
mettre en place aucune filière de
souveraineté si ce n'est celle de là
finances de la start up née schott à
terre que aujourd'hui une start up est
d'abord un produit financier avant de
créer un produit ou d emplois je ne vois
pas en fait ce moment cela peut
fonctionner avec le poids de la dette
qu'ovide qui va nous être imposée est la
difficulté de la finance et
puisqu'aujourd'hui les gars femmes
mais évidemment on les moyens d'empêcher
cette accession qui sont demandées par
les gouvernants en place et n'oubliez
surtout pas votre pass annie terre si
vous allez au restaurant très
prochainement
je savais que ça nous ferait plaisir
c'était la petite dédicace de fin de
saison vers 6 à vous au royaume uni la
levée des restrictions sanitaires sera
bien le 19 juillet le premier ministre
britannique l'a rappelé hier boris
johnson mise sur la responsabilité
individuelle de ses concitoyens alors
que le nombre de cas dus aux variants
delta est en hausse et que la campagne
de vaccination s'essouffle florian
lambert
soixante mille personnes réunies dans le
stade de wembley à londres invariants
delta qui inquiète au vu de
l'augmentation du nombre de cas en
angleterre et pourtant boris johnson
s'est exprimé ce lundi pour confirmer la
levée de l'essentiel des dernières
restrictions outre-manche restaurer les
libertés et se reposer sur la
responsabilité individuelle de chacun
voilà en substance le message adressé
par le premier ministre britannique lors
de cette conférence de presse nous en
tiendrons à notre plan pour lever les
restrictions juridiques et la
distanciation sociale
nous attendons à ce que les gens portent
un masque dans les espaces bondé pour
des raisons de responsabilité sociale
nous exhortons les boîtes de nuit et
d'autres lieux où la foule est nombreuse
à utiliser le pass and i ter qui montre
une preuve de vaccination un test
négatif récents ou une immunité
naturelle comme moyen d'entrer marc
lovay minutes et des mines
concrètement le port du masque et la
dispensation sociales ne sont plus
obligatoires
une décision forte de sens alors que le
royaume uni
koné le pire bilan de la pandémie en
europe avec plus de 128 mille décès liés
au coït 19,6 la campagne de vaccination
a permis à 65 % des adultes de recevoir
lors de doses
elle commence déjà à montrer des signes
d'essoufflement notamment auprès des
jeunes adultes
initialement prévue le 21 juin cette
levée des restrictions avaient été
repoussées en raison de la reprise des
contaminations dues aux variantes delta
il n'en reste pas moins que sur la seule
journée du 9 juillet 2021
trente cinq mille nouveaux cas ont été
enregistrés ce qui ne manque pas de
susciter l'inquiétude au sein de la
communauté scientifique
le nombre de cas augmente
considérablement
avec plus de 30 il contamination par
jour et nous pouvons voir ce qu'il se
passe en europe alors que le variant
delta prend racine parmi nous nous
savons qu'il y aura davantage
d'hospitalisations et de décès liés au
vide 19
mais nous savons aussi que cette vague
était clairement prévu par nos
scientifiques
lorsque nous avons est à vie cette
feuille de route enfilé n'est pas une
faible cette levée des restrictions
sanitaires concernera donc uniquement
l'angleterre l'ecosse le pays de galles
et l'irlande du nord ont opté pour une
levée des restrictions sanitaires plus
progressive
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis battre au royaume uni avec bharat
un pan kahniens expert en maladies
infectieuses à l'université d'exeter
c'est notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir battant le kenya merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france en
outre manche 1 on l'a entendu les
contaminations qui flanc mais les décès
qui reste relativement stable
comment cela s'explique benefit of
boxing et non 5 bénéficie t vaccin qui
est maintenant visible mais je ne suis
pas d'accord avec le premier ministre
boris johnson qui a établi un lien entre
les vaccins
qui a dit que le lien entre les vaccins
et la mort était complètement brisée
c'est le lien entre les vaccins et
l'hospitalisation tout forme grâce qui a
été affaiblie en d'autres termes le
vaccin protège la majorité de la
population pas tous le même mais la
majorité de la population
voilà ce que nous observons actuellement
au royaume uni qu'on soit bien clair ça
veut dire toujours que les vaccinés
échappe aux formes graves dans leur
grande majorité et donc à la mort c'est
c'est toujours le cas ce postulat bar à
tapas en khâgne à tout à fait correct
c'est bien le cas les personnes qui ont
jeté complètement vaccinés dans la
majorité des cas sauf systématiquement
son protégé était forme grave de la
maladie et bien sûr de la mort le
gouvernement britannique en appelle donc
choisi en tout cas la responsabilité
individuelle 1 ça ne sent pas
nécessairement le cas vous l'avez
peut-être vu en france dans ces
conditions que vous venez nous expliquer
est ce que le gouvernement britannique a
donc raison de lever les restrictions
ceux qui ont voulu se faire vacciner se
sont fait vacciner les autres peut-être
assume les conséquences éventuelles
ce problème là oui il ya un problème
we are moving l'instruction d'une part
nous devons les restrictions auxquelles
ses cibles donc le nombre de cas aux
blondes et mais le grand problème ce que
si l'on lève les restrictions avec une
augmentation du nombre de cas d'une part
et d'autre part l'augmentation des
admissions à l'hôpital qui restent à
venir lever toutes les mesures de
contrôle et de la propagation tels que
par exemple le port du masque dans les
bus les trains alors on se dirige droit
vers le mur car le gens ne porteront pas
le masque volontairement fait on ne
forcera plus les gens à forcer le masque
donc il va y avoir un problème à
l'avenir
parmi les non vaccinés il y a beaucoup
de jeunes on l'a entendue dans ce sujet
pour pour quelle raison est ce qu'on a
du mal peut-être à convaincre les
parents d'aller faire vacciner des
enfants aux mineurs in by clicking pour
le moment vacciner les personnes à
partir de 18 ans pour ce qu'il faut et
faire pour l'instant les populations ses
conseillers informer former les
bénéfices de la vaccination qui sont
multiples d'une part le vaccin protège
de youtube on peut sauver la vie de
quelqu'un et également 3e le vaccin peut
protéger
contre ce qu'on appelle l'auto ville en
fait c'est à dire qu'on est contaminée
il se remet et puis il reste en fait
beaucoup de problèmes de santé ensuite
le vaccin protège contre cette forme de
la maladie également
il faut étudier former et conseiller
vous nous dites la vaccination c'est à
partir de 18 ans au royaume uni c'est
vrai quoi on peut s'en étonner et s'en
émouvoir un petit peu en france où notre
président nous a annoncé hier un pas
sanitaires à partir de 12 ans ça veut
dire qu'en gros il y aura des campagnes
de vaccination dans les collèges à la
rentrée vous en tant que infectiologues
est ce que vous trouvez ça raisonnable
tout à fait raisonnable c'est une très
bonne approche
les etats unis le canada israël les pays
bas et je suis très heureux de
l'entendre la france adopté cette
approche font vacciner à partir de 12
ans je me fasse la même chose et c'est
magnifique
il ya d'énormes bénéfices à vacciner à
partir de 12 ans aucune par les enfants
doivent être continuellement peuvent
transmettre la maladie et cela mène à
une augmentation des cas deuxièmement
les écoles doivent rester ouverts afin
d'éviter un système d'arrêt et de
redémarrage car maman il faut vacciner
les enfants à partir de 12 ans afin que
les écoles puissent rester ouverte et
bien fonctionné de plus les enfants
peuvent être contaminés et les enfants
peuvent contracter une femme une longue
de lakovic donc la vaccination est
efficace également pour les enfants à
partir de 12 ans sans fin un jour tout
d'un camp invariants pourrait apparaître
qui pourrait causer des formes très
grave que la maladie chez les jeunes
enfants s'ils sont déjà vaccinés avec un
vaccin alors il pourrait avoir
une certaine protection contre ce phare
y en a qui pourraient être dangereux
pour les jeunes merci beaucoup baraton
cagna d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rt france dans quelques instants
rester avec nous manifestation à cuba
des autorités américaines disent suivre
avec attention la situation et puis le
retour en france de la dépouille du
général que d'un mort en 1812 pendant la
campagne russe de napoléon
[Musique]
oui
vous allez vous vous consacrez au
festival du film russe à paris qui est
intitulé quand les russes ne bouleverse
nous bouleverse toujours vous savez
parce qu'on les comprend pas il nous
touche
ils nous font pleurer et on sait pas
pourquoi l'objectif réel profond que
vous avez là c'est c'est quoi c'est de
faire de la pédagogie c'est de faire
mieux que ça c'est de recréer des liens
que la politique n'arrive plus à renault
alors c'est à dire que la culture c'est
au dessus de tout ça le cinéma nous dit
des vérités que nous disent personne ni
les politiques ni les ambassadeurs ni
les journalistes et nous sommes même si
rien c'est la même culture c'est la même
façon de penser
les mêmes physique je pense qu'il ya une
union qui va se rétablir c'est pas
possible autrement
et de toute façon ils ont besoin de nous
comme nous avons besoin d'eux je suis
optimiste
peut-être pas tout de suite il faut
passer au delà de quelques quelques
obstacles mais je crois que l'avenir est
allemand
chaque jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs sont joués mais les
règles ne sont pas toujours respectées
les couleurs changent de camp les pions
prennent la place des rois de films
stratégie peut porter des résultats
inattendus
[Musique]
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire
[Musique]
je suis l'ex maire et chaque semaine
dans l'échiquier mondial nous
analyserons les coups les plus complexes
du jeu politique internationale
à bientôt sur rt france 21h34 souhaité
bienvenue en direct sur rt france à cuba
une centaine de personnes ont été
arrêtées après les manifestations de
dimanche
lille qui est durement frappée par une
crise économique et sanitaire avait vu
la population manifester la situation de
cuba est suivie avec attention par les
autorités américaines pour plus de
précisions on retrouve tout de suite
notre reporter thomas bonnet en direct
de washington bonsoir thomas comment
l'administration maiden agit-elle sur ce
dossier épineux
bonsoir stéphanie et bien quelques
heures seulement après le début des
manifestations à cuba on avait déjà des
réactions américaines
des réactions qui s'enchaînent depuis ce
dimanche avec d'abord le conseiller à la
sécurité nationale puis une membre du
département d'état américain est encore
tout récemment le porte parole du
département d'état net price qui appelle
dit il
les dirigeants de cuba à faire preuve de
retenue à respecter la voix du peuple en
ouvrant tous les moyens de communication
en ligne et hors ligne voilà le genre de
déclaration qui sont donc régulièrement
délivré par les autorités américaines
même le président américain joe biden a
pris position publiquement il ya
quelques jours je propose de l'écouter
je veux commencer par reconnaître les
remarquables manifestations qui ont lieu
à cuba que le peuple cubain exigent sa
libération d'un régime autoritaire et je
ne pense pas que nous ayons vécu quelque
chose comme cette manifestation depuis
très très longtemps et je dirais même
jamais
et les etats unis se tiennent aux côtés
du peuple cubain alors qu'ils font
valoir leurs droits universels et nous
appelons le gouvernement quand le
gouvernement de cuba à s'abstenir de
toute violence ou de tenter de faire
taire la voix du peuple de cuba alors la
rapidité de la réaction américaine
contraste quelque peu avec d'autres
sujets si on prend l'exemple de la
situation en colombie où il ya aussi des
manifestations violentes depuis
plusieurs semaines les états unis
n'avaient pas été aussi prompts à
condamner publiquement ce qu'il se
déroule en colombie il faut dire que
l'administration de la maison blanche
soutient le président colombien en place
alors pour les autorités cubaines il
s'agit là d'une nouvelle illustration de
l'interventionnisme américain selon le
chef de la diplomatie cubaine et bien
washington soutient d'une façon ou d'une
autre la campagne numérique
elle serait ce qu basse et un hashtag
qui a été beaucoup utilisés par les
manifestants que ce soit à cuba mais
aussi au sein de la communauté cubaine
qui vit aux états unis
et puis pour le président de cuba miguel
diaz cannelle
les etats unis sont en grande partie
responsables de la situation dans le
pays parce qu'ils ont mis leur place ce
fameux blocus économique
ecoutez-le tous ces processus que nous
avons essayé d'affronter de vaincre face
à une politique d' asphyxie économique
pour provoquer des troubles sociaux dans
le pays ont des effets cumulatifs et je
crois précisément aujourd'hui les
problèmes que nous vivons ce
lié à ces processus alors pour le
secrétaire d'état anthony blinken il
s'agit d'une grave erreur ce sont ces
mots que de blâmer les états unis pour
une quelconque implication dans la
situation à cuba mais il faut quand même
rappeler que l'embargo qui est en place
depuis maintenant 60 ans a été condamné
à de très nombreuses reprises par la
communauté internationale il faut aussi
rappeler que joe biden lors de la
dernière campagne présidentielle avait
fait une promesse celle de revenir sur
la politique mise en place par donald
trump à l'égard de cuba une politique
très dure mais selon les informations de
cnn et bien les équipes de joe biden
planche toujours sur la bonne stratégie
à adopter pour ce dossier un dossier
particulièrement délicat dès qu'on parle
de cuba ici aux etats unis cela fait
ressortir les vieux réflexes anti
communiste notamment auprès des élus
républicains ils sont très durs ils sont
un discours très agressif depuis
plusieurs jours on en pense notamment à
certains élus républicains de floride où
vit évidemment une grande communauté
cubaine je vous dirais par exemple le la
teneur des discours de tête cruz qui est
sénateur républicain du texas qui est
d'origine cubaine qui exhorte
l'administration de joe biden à tenir
une position très sévère à l'endroit du
pouvoir tuba merci thomas abonnés pour
en parler nous sommes en direct par
téléphone avec gérald ollivier
journaliste franco américain chercheurs
alips bonsoir gerald olivier merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous clairement joe
biden va devoir gérer ce dossier cubain
qui n'était pas une priorité pour lui
oui bonsoir non non je n'étais pas du
tout une priorité
la preuve c'est que son administration
avait laissé en place les sanctions qui
avaient été réintroduites vers la fin de
l'administration de demain trempe il
faut racler très brièvement que les
relations entre les etats-unis et cuba
ont été pratiquement gelée de 1960 à
2015 d'abord du fait de la guerre froide
et puis après du fait que cuba a trouvé
un nouvel allié avec le venezuela et que
les états unis ont maintenu
une politique d'embargo visant à faire
tomber le régime de l'intérieur en
quelque sorte les sens que cela produise
des faits c'est le président obama qui
avait changé cette politique à partir de
on avait parlé à des tombes de déchets
le dégel cubain il avait levé l'embargo
il avait rétabli des relations
commerciales les etats-unis ont ouvert
une ambassade à cuba en 2015 la fameuse
visite du président obama en mars 2016 à
cuba première visite d'un président
américain en plus de 81 ans et depuis
les choses allaient beaucoup mieux au
sein de l'île si ce n'est que les
républicains et en particulier donald
trump ont jugé que les américains
avaient ouvert le robinet permettant au
régime et à l'économie cubaine d'aller
beaucoup mieux sans pour autant que le
régime évolué dans sa promotion des
droits de l'homme son respect des droits
de l'homme sa promotion des libertés
individuelles même des liberté
d'entreprendre des libertés économiques
ce qui fait que vers la fin de son
mandat
donald trump a rétabli un certain nombre
de sanctions en particulier il a rétabli
la liste de cuba enfin la présence de
cuba sur la liste des états considérés
comme sponsor du terrorisme
il a interdit les transferts d'argent
des états unis vers cuba
ce qui a provoqué une crise économique
quasiment instantané à cuba cela cumulé
avec le co vide
on a aujourd'hui la situation que l'on
constate mais l'administration byden
quand elle est arrivée elle n'a rien
fait pour revenir sur les positions
prises par l'administration trump est en
quelque sorte
elle attendait de voir donc c'est une
crise en effet qu'elle ne souhaitait pas
avoir à traiter selon donald trump un
joe biden doit s'opposer je cite au
régime communiste
sinon dit-il et l'histoire s'en
rappellera qu est ce que ça veut dire
concrètement est-ce qu'il n'y aurait de
vraies devant ce diagnostic est ce que
ça rappelle c'est que l'opposition entre
cuba et les etats unis c'est une
opposition qui est ancré dans la guerre
froide
il faut rappeler que cubain s'est c'est
le première je dirais incidents de
l'impérialisme en quelque sorte des
états unis
les relations entre cuba et les etats
unis remonte au 19e siècle
les etats-unis ont soutenu cuba dans sa
guerre de libération contre l'espagne
l'espoir à l'époque était que cuba
intégrerait le giron américain des états
unis avaient cherché à acheter nil
plusieurs fois à l'espagne sans succès
les cubains ont préféré leur
indépendance et ils l'ont obtenue sous
une forme de protectorat américain
protectorat dans le cadre duquel les
américains ont hérité de cette fameuse
base à guantanamo avec un bail
renouvelable de 99 ans et qui est
aujourd'hui deuxième fois séculaire donc
il y avait cette relation je dirais de
clients entre les etats-unis et cuba une
relation qui s'est envenimée avec la
présidence de batista dans les années 50
et quand fidel castro est arrivé les
américains ont laissé batista tomber
espérant sans doute faire tomber castro
derrière malheureusement castro s'est
réfugiée dans les bras de l'union
soviétique alors et on a eu une
situation entre autres la fameuse crise
des missiles cubains durant laquelle le
monde est passé à quelques à quelques
doigts on va dire quelques centimètres
de la crise thermonucléaire comme on
disait à l'époque les relations entre
les deux pays ont alors été gelés et les
etats unis ont toujours agi sur la base
que cuba était un régime communiste et
que le devoir des états unis était de
s'opposer à tout régime communiste de
tout faire pour qu'il y ait un
changement de régime sur place donc la
politique du président obama qui
consistait à chercher à faire une sorte
de je dirais travail et de l'intérieur
laissez le régime s'ouvrir à travers une
forme d'ouverture économique devait
déboucher sur une ouverture politique
quand cela n'a pas fonctionné et qu'au
contraire on a
assistaient pas plus tard d'ailleurs que
ce printemps je rappelle qu'il y a eu un
congrès un congrès du parti communiste
cuba autre attente qui a confirmé la
présidence de monsieur miguel diaz
cannelle à la présidence comme
successeur des frères castro est une
sorte de je dirais pérennisation du
régime
à partir de là les etats-unis sont dans
leurs droits historiques de chercher à
faire tomber ce régime puisque ils se
sont toujours opposés au communisme
partout où il cherchait à s'étendre
merci beaucoup gérald ollivier
journaliste franco américain cherchera
lips merci d'avoir été avec nous ils
nous avoir apporté votre analyse la
france rechigné à récupérer la dépouille
du général que d'un mort en russie
pendant la campagne de napoléon sadate
de 1812 à deux jours de l'arrivée de
l'avion avec les restes du général de l'
empire l'elysée a rompu le silence est
la ministre des anciens combattants je
ne lève darrieussecq à lui a finalement
rendu hommage à son arrivée au bourget
vers goffman plus de 200 ans après sa
mort près de smolensk le général gul un
fidèle de napoléon s'envole enfin vers
sa patrie mais la politique c'est tout
de même mêlé de cet événement historique
il était prévu que le général français
rejoigne son ami souverain aux invalides
lors d'une cérémonie d'hommage en
présence de vladimir poutine emmanuel
macron le 5 mai le jour du bicentenaire
de la mort de napoléon
or le rapatriement de la dépouille
retrouvée en 2019 a été d'abord reporté
pour des raisons sanitaires ensuite
classé la france n'ayant pas dépenser un
centime pour toute l'opération c'est un
oligarque russe qui a prêté son avion à
la fondation pour le développement des
initiatives historique franco-russe à
l'origine de la découverte archéologique
pour transporter les restes du général
gudin en france ça a été complètement
annulé au mois d'avril l'année dernière
mais le dossier a même pas été gelés il
a été classé donc ça veut dire que
cubain devait être enterré ici en russie
et ce qui donc j'ai pris la décision moi
même pas de le rapatrier à travers il ya
énormément de loin vous doutez bien et
un très grand protocole avec la famille
est de trouver un avion pour pouvoir le
rapatrier mais maintenant qu'on leur
amène et que l'elysée a réagi qu'on aura
une ministre à l'arrivée tout est
possible
moi j'ai quelques informations bien sûr
mais qui élit le président vladimir
poutine ça je sais pas ça sera
maintenant de la nouvelle politique de
la nouvelle diplomatie ça me concerne
plus une fois que j'ai rendu le corps
maintenant le corps appartient la france
l'est et en russie maintenant il va
appartenir à la france
maintenant c'est au président de la
république de décider s'il veut inviter
le président poutine
mais dans tous les cas le corps ce sera
en france et il sera honoré comme il
comme il le mérite je peux que féliciter
quand même le président de la république
d'avoir réagi il ya deux jours est de
vouloir faire quelque chose à l'arrivée
ça va être je pense grandiose maintenant
mais jusque maintenant j'ai pas à
remercier puisqu'on a fait tout seul
malgré les hésitations des autorités
françaises le général gudin recevra les
honneurs qui lui était due en france en
russie déjà c'est l'ambassadeur de
france qui s'est dit ému de l'événement
je voulais vous dire simplement que
c'était un moment un moment très
émouvant
le général gudin retrouve sa sa famille
retrouve la terre de france
il s'est battu dans la grande armée il a
perdu la vie ici il a été retrouvé grâce
à des recherches archéologiques franco
franco-russe donc c'est un grand moment
qui montre aussi cette histoire partagée
que nous avons entre la russie et la
france
côté russe on se félicite du symbole que
représente le rapatriement de la
dépouille du général que d'un en france
un moment de réconciliation entre les
deux pays
pour moi cet événement est vraiment un
vrai rayon du soleil aujourd'hui parce
que cet événement est à la fois
diplomatique politique culturelle et
historique donc c'est un événement
historique qui peut être rentrer sur les
pages des livres d'histoire dans le
climat politique actuel et les relations
franco-russes plus que vos froid 10 ans
moment d'unité ne serait pas à négliger
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
christian hambourg des présidents de
paris napoléon 2021 associations en
charge de la cérémonie bonsoir christian
bourdeilles merci d'être avec nous alors
la découverte de son corps en 2019 et
son rapatriement aujourd'hui peut-être
considéré comme un moment important de
l'histoire de france c'est comme ça que
en tout cas vous vous le voyez déjà
c'est effectivement très rare qu'un
général de la grande armée reviennent
deux cents ans après par un avion est
donc déjà ça c'est vraiment à saluer
donc c'est un grand jour historique de
bien montrer que finalement avec un
petit peu donc de talent le talent de
pierre bel et 9 ski parce que c'est lui
qui a découvert donc la tombe donc un
peu oubliée donc du général guide à
smolensk donc de le faire revenir et de
faire revivre effectivement une page
d'histoire une page d'histoire entre la
russie et la france donc ça c'est
vraiment tout à fait intéressant est de
bien montrer que cette relation
historique est bien vivante c'est pas
simplement quelque chose de complètement
oublié c'est encore 200 ans après donc
une empreinte un no man's land avait lui
être rendu comme on le disait le 5 mai
dernier lors du bicentenaire de la mort
de napoléon mais finalement annulé vous
en connaissez les raisons précises
moi je pense que déjà le contexte
sanitaire en france le 5 mai ne se
prêtait pas donc à une grande
manifestation
d'autre part c'était le 5 mai donc le
jour anniversaire de la mort de
l'empereur napoléon 1er bon peut-être
que c'était pas forcément la meilleure
date
cela étant maintenant se projette vers
l'avenir
donc déjà une bonne chose ce soir le
général gudin donc est en france
sur le sol français et ça c'est très
important
maintenant il ya une dernière étape donc
de savoir où il va reposer pour
l'éternité soit dans son petit village
de saint maurice sur aviron donc dans le
loyer ou alors effectivement est ce que
le président de la république va prendre
la décision de le placer aux invalides
et aujourd'hui nous avons eu quand même
des éléments d'information nouveau grâce
madame la ministre déléguée aux armées
madame darrieussecq
alors quelles sont ces informations et
puis la question aussi évidemment que
j'ai envie de vous poser vous le
connaisseur de napoléon c'est at il
justement ça passe général gueu d'un aux
invalides
alors effectivement donc il ya deux
aspects alors ce cet après midi donc au
bourget lorsque nous avons accueilli
donc le cercueil du général plus d'un
donc madame darrieussecq a dit que pour
elle
et donc il n'y avait plus de difficultés
pour que le général gudin puisse reposer
donc aux invalides donc on enlève
extrêmement heureux et cette décision
donc est une décision qui était sûrement
prise au plus haut niveau des autorités
de la république française donc je ne
peux que m'en réjouir
et ça n'est farah tout ce débat qui a eu
lieu ces dernières semaines
alors maintenant effectivement il ya
encore un débat même un débat au sein
des instances historique voire des
instances napoléonienne est ce que le
général bida on qui n'est pas un grand
maréchal de lempire est ce que le
général bida mérite d'être placées dans
le caveau des gouverneurs des arêtes
alors moi je réponds tout de suite oui
parce que c'est ça qui est intéressant
en cette année 2011 21 l'année donc du
bicentenaire de la mort de l'empereur
napoléon 1er je crois qu'il est
intéressant aussi de ne pas oublier tous
ceux ils étaient nombreux
simple soldat des sous-officiers des
officiers des généraux qui ont aidé donc
la carrière fulgurante de l'empereur
napoléon 1er et comme par hasard alors
est ce que c'est un hasard ou pas
moi je dirais que c'est par hasard et
bien c'est le général gul a qui est donc
désigné par voilà là les fouilles
archéologiques c'est lui qu'on a
retrouvée et je pense que c'est un beau
symbole donc de faire en sorte que le
général guida soit le porte-parole
certaine façon de tous ces soldats de la
grande armée qui ont été sacrifiés et
encore une fois le général gudin il est
mort parce que lui il a eu une jambe
donc emporté donc donc sur le plateau de
valentine et agoras il est décédé à
smolensk donc il est mort au combat et
je pense que c'est une belle figure et
napoléon lui-même disait que les
qualités morales donc du général gudas
en faisait donc un exemple pour toute la
grande armée eh bien je trouve encore
une fois est-ce que c'est le hasard
moi je crois pas au hasard donc da c'est
lui qui en cette année 2010 21 va être
un petit peu le porte parole si je peux
dire si jo cette expression est bien de
tous les soldats de la grande armée donc
et de reposer auprès donc de l'empereur
napoléon 1er alors que je vous rappelle
que gudin et a été donc un condisciple
donc du jeune petit corse napoléon
bonaparte puisqu'ils se sont rencontrés
budin avait 11 ans et napoléon avis dix
ans donc c'est une vraie histoire
personnelle entre les deux personnages
et je pense que guy d'un mérite
amplement donc de pouvoir reposer aux
invalides il a toutes les qualités
morales s'était vraiment à un officier
brillant un officier qui est je rappelle
qu'ils étaient nobles et qui a fait le
choix de la révolution et l'empiré
merci beaucoup question bourdeilles je
rappelle que vous êtes un président de
paris napoléon 2020 d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france et c'est la
fin de cette émission merci de l'avoir
suivi prochain point complet sur
l'actualité dans quelques minutes
et
[Musique]
est ce que vous répondez quand on vous
soupçonne et on soupçonne votre
industrie d'être sulfureuse et
industriels est extrêmement contrôlée
quoi puisque on reverse 50 5 % de notre
chiffre d'affaires à l'état et à la
commune qui sont donc très intéressé au
fait que le
fonctionnement soit clean on fait
exactement comme les banques les
compagnies d'assurances est ce qu il ya
de l'argent suspect nous sommes dans
l'obligation de le déclarer
comment se répartit 100 euros de mise
globalement aux machines à sou par
exemple moi j'ai dans l'obligation de
rendre en moyenne 85%
nous on n'a absolument aucun intérêt à
ce que quelqu'un aille raconter qu'il
chérit les au casino pas certains
pouvaient dépenser des sommes
extrêmement importantes allant jusqu'aux
millions d'euros aujourd'hui ça n'existe
et on est beaucoup plus dans le loisir
aujourd'hui ce qui fait notre marge
c'est la fréquentation et le nombre